today's guest is a fellow Louisiana
native comedian he is he is
one-of-a-kind you can see him tonight at
the La Jolla comedy store in San Diego
and touring all across America ladies
and gentlemen mr. mark Norman
[Music]
yeah I'll just like heaven what it is
man this year I see guys I started
feeling like someone comfortable
sometimes that sometimes it gives me
like a little bit of like uh I don't for
almost makes you feel like I'm in like
disguise almost sunglasses do you feel
better with sunglasses on it's like a
poker game I want you to know what I'm
doing you know yeah yeah I think I have
this constant perception of this
constant fear something that everybody
knows what I'm thinking even though they
don't look people in the eye cuz every
like their can see it in my head oh you
know weird this is all gold by the way
we're missing it yeah we got it
no these chairs are yeah um this is nice
man good digs yeah thanks man we've been
a little over three years that we've
been podcasting now this is the new
medium this is changing the game you
know it's interesting huh yeah New York
is way behind yeah why is that do you
feel like New York is behind in the
podcast world well we're such purist
[ __ ] you know or vipra we think we're
cool and great and it's all about the
art and then over here you guys are like
well I'd like to make some money yeah
you know and we don't have any money
look at Dave Attell Dave Attell is
brilliant comedian funniest guy on the
planet he's walking around with a CVS
bag yeah and a black hoodie on and we
said he had graffiti on his back hey
probably fell asleep at a train station
and then Joe Rogan is you know driving
17 cars and living in a warehouse you
know so drinking space blood yeah yeah
yeah so we gotta we gotta take a little
note from you guys on that yeah but it's
kind of picking up you have a podcast oh
yeah oh yeah Tuesday's of stories baby
it's cooking finally and um and I know
people love Chris de Stefano and Yanis
is podcast they're killing it they're
killing it Tim Dylan we got heat mega
moved here actually he moved here now
that fat homo I know haven't well you
got we got Schultz yeah you got Schultz
over there all right dirrection yeah
he's got that
I know it kills that guy is a marketing
guru he's wild bro he's such a sand
Christian and he doesn't when you look
at him he has a very if you look at
Andrew Schultz where do you feel like
he's from I feel like he has the most
and big yeah I don't know what ambiguous
means juhi Middle Eastern II or could be
Italian could be Russian yeah you're
right
he's got the cheese stash and that
throws you off it's his uber driver is
he a DJ yeah yeah we're dropping we were
black though yes yes exactly and he
would know about all the cool nightclubs
and yeah he'd have PDFs are probably
some policy in the trunk trunk [ __ ]
that's the best kind something would be
in the trunk that was for sale if he
were driving over black right right yes
like old VCRs or some share blu-ray I've
been in a blu-ray what is blu-ray I've
always heard about it is that the uber
black of DVD I think it is I think it's
just something else that they tried to
like really upsell people on cuz I don't
think it really blooper he never really
took off well I worked at Blockbuster
not bragging and it was like the blu-ray
section was like oh [ __ ] look at this
guy was like VIP it was velvet roped and
that bottleservice over there it was
different but I never got it yeah I
never I never had blue actually it
scared me because it seemed like it
wasn't gonna catch on yes yes exactly
exactly that's why I never did it like
Bitcoin yeah I heard there was a sorry
there was a huge fight in the beginning
between HD DVDs and blu-ray they were
kind of like similar both better than
regular DVDs but blu-ray one because the
porn industry adopted it Oh
porn is big mmm porn is so powerful do
you watch I try not to watch but I have
watched probably within the last 11
hours the same same yeah I had a block
on my phone and it quit working when I
once the block work to my phone it
worked for about two and a half years
you had a [ __ ] blocker yeah Wow
bro it wiped it out of my eye there was
no I can't access it on my computer but
on my phone I can and uh I need to get a
new blocker yeah the game when I got the
phone blocker I was off for months and
months well you know port is dangerous
because if you don't watch it for five
days and then you look at it again
you're like whoa like it comes all back
to you like this is amazing
but it's bad for you it hits all the
senses it's too much it's like ketchup
it's too dark yeah yeah yeah and you can
see anal and Asians and Jews it's tough
and are there a Jew section on there I
don't know there should be there should
be like like Nazi porn yeah there's
every other kind of porn this race is
porn there is that's a category racist
pool yeah and it's like you know oh I
got the Asian and they throw an egg
rolls at her and [ __ ] I mean I didn't
make that up that's real
yeah no let's see it doesn't seem like
something you would just fabricate if it
was it'd be pretty good
China has Nazi theme bars oh I could see
that yeah but it's not like we hate Jews
just they are existed and you know
that's a theme the China have you've
been over there do stand I did some
Shanghai and I'd saw the Great Wall and
all that yeah not not a humorous people
I mean we're doing better now with the
the Ali Wong's
is she Chinese oh boy here we go I'm
Shane Gillis thing right now but yeah
yeah and he's enough I think yeah yeah
something's up Ronny Chang he's got to
be China he's gotta be China if he's not
Chinese dude then we quit
yeah he's if he's not Chinese he's
Russian won't you oh she's from Pacific
Heights she's from San Francisco oh so
there you go yeah it's Chinatown yeah
this is the Charlotte that's the trolley
Chinese they call him she's very very
funny a big fan of the Wong yeah
Oh Kobe so I went in a porn hub last
night I went to the search cuz I like
the compilations and Kobe Bryant was the
first first thing that popped up Wow
in that while that means that some
people mourn people want to get in there
and see Kobe Bryant pornography I think
it's women that look like Kobe or is it
is it man and I didn't I didn't click on
it but I think it's I guess ladies or
gay guys they're like I want to oh [ __ ]
or watch a Kobe like guy [ __ ] I'm sure
there's a lot of men who are getting uh
like kind of lean gay men who are black
men tall men yeah I'm probably extra
work right now yes yes isn't that weird
like this guy died let's bring him in
yeah do you have a jersey come on over
yeah I wouldn't think like that you know
I liked Ralphie May but I'm not googling
that although he's not sexy but yeah but
I'm not gonna eat 40 tight
Jirka exactly exactly and r.i.p Ralphy
man that's so crazy how it's so wild how
quickly someone goes from being here to
being gone isn't it it's just so yeah
yeah yeah
and it's an eye-opener you kind of go
[ __ ] I could go in any minute I got
family and then my friends and what if
they go and yeah II had a lot more to do
I feel like do you yeah that's the
feeling and also and also that he just
got done really working like yeah I know
that whole stretch of like being a
athlete like even though it's glorified
and stuff a lot of times and it's a
popular job and people love seeing it
it's also it's still a ton of work it's
like oh yeah man was warp me played in
those other leagues you played on the
Olympic teams and that was working for
20 years totally totally and it's kind
of why he crashed cuz he was he was
doing so much that he couldn't sit in LA
traffic so he had to get helicopters but
I'm not a big NBA guy but I watched his
documentary and it blew my mind because
it relates to stand up you can put a you
know a parallel and just hard-working
and what there's a story of him he went
to basketball camp as a kid and like
three months of camp didn't score one
basket not one and he said he felt like
I'd let his dad down because that was a
player he let his uncle down and then he
just kept working and became the best
yeah I think that's one thing that like
cuz I've never been a big Kobe fan I was
a big Jordan fan yeah you know Zions got
me back into the embrace I'm with the
Pels ion yes exciting but I always
marveled at how what how he had people
from around the world really gravitated
towards him yeah yeah and I'm marveled
at his work ethic it just seemed like
there was nobody else like in the fourth
quarter of games and stuff who was who
it seemed like not only wanted the ball
but it was it was gonna be able to
handle it better than anybody yeah yeah
and he was tough and scary and
competitive but I feel like as he grew
he got more gentle and and loving like
he would shout out to the younger guys
like it's going great
and we've all been you know when you
start out and staying up you're like
who's this young [ __ ] guzzler coming up
on my heels and then after a while
you're like wait I'm good he's good why
can't we all be good yeah and I'm gonna
give a nice tweet do you think like was
there something that like like say when
like a
like that happens is there something
that you kind of think like like I
sometimes I wonder like where does it
hit me like does it hit me that I'm like
like scared of like leaving scared of
missing people like I wonder like what
is it about like specifically about
death that like you know really gets me
the most well I think it's a coupling
one it's it's just so final there's no
like next try or let me redo and then
right there's no more email there's not
like another II you don't get another
email nothing nothing you know you write
a bad tweet you delete it you write
another one this is it your typos out
there too you want to be you want to
have put like a little dent on the earth
a little bit like have some videos some
photos some change and he's got kids
ah the whole thing sucks it should have
been a should have been curry her you
think no I'm joking I'm sure it would
have been two hours I think if you if it
would have been Sam Perkins you remember
him from the Sonics gonna bring Wow pull
up perky yeah it's been a while he's one
of the first extremely stoned players to
play well but also Kobe he shot a three
into the stands one time no wrong way
yeah wow that's yeah one of a cut to
death for that I was picturing a white
guy Sam Perkins I don't remember him oh
yeah one of a kind
dude and he definitely oh look at those
of course he has in there yeah it's
sideways like a diagonal corn yeah like
they're kind of like the Asian corn like
when they planted on the mountain he
played at North Carolina with Michael
Jordan to AH he was one of a kind
um so cool is there is there a lie
sometimes I you know what I sadly is
when I think about dying I don't want to
have like lies out there that I've told
oh yeah because if everything's just at
that point it's like when you it it's
all coming out yeah yeah that's it and
you can't fix it you have no control and
if you die like that
that's it yeah so you did you're [ __ ]
yeah I used to think sometimes I never
however you died that that's how you
like are in heaven so I like this you
know yeah then you gotta walk around
like that yeah but isn't heaven supposed
to be perfect and great and all that
yeah I don't think they do like a lot of
like car
work up yeah they're not doing Botox
yeah they're not remodeling your for you
get there you show up like if you got
hit by a train but that means everybody
in heaven is gonna be all black and
shit-faced and weird and run flat from
being run over or smushed yeah I think
it'll be fun immediately what happened
right I guess you got a bunch of dog
bites on you that's a tough way yeah
yeah you got a bullet hole right here
immediately yeah people have that bullet
hole like some guys why run with a spear
he's 500 years old musket wound scurvy
AIDS yeah it's so scary man it's just so
and just has no control you have no
control over it either and when I got
back to LA I felt it at the airport it
was like oh man like you know there's
just so many Kobe fans I know I know
many and it's kind of nice that in this
world of cancelling and PC and all that
that he he got in trouble for whatever
he did I don't want to get into it yeah
and we can still mourn the guy we don't
have to sit there and go well actually
it's like shut up let us have this the
guy's dead enough with your [ __ ]
right you know well yeah and I think
that it's one of the reminder yeah it's
like almost this it's almost like this
so necessary reminder for Humanity that
we all have so many mistakes yes there's
this there's this weird like crush or
especially with social media where it's
this perfection that's not yeah it's so
unrealistic I know like in the 90s it
was hey nobody's perfect and now it's
hey if you're not perfect we'll figure
it out and kill you yeah and then it's
annoys me I don't want to get to qui fee
on here but these douches on Twitter
that just [ __ ] on you your homophobia
racism and then I got kills himself and
they go hey if you're feeling sad reach
out what do you do about it's like you
did this you're the you're the piece of
[ __ ] you're the poison out here you're
ruining us stop yelling at me you
[ __ ] [ __ ] ah drives me crazy Joe I
was listening to Brogan last night at
the comedy story and honestly like he
has some new material that some of the
no joke some of the best stuff of it oh
yeah Wow it's just so good man and it's
it's it's exactly about like that kind
of stuff to cancel culture in this the
level like how just it's some people
that are doing all of this
it's the loud voice yes yeah yeah and
then what's weird when you know you see
these people on Twitter going oh shut up
cancel cultures not a thing get over
yourself and you're like well I mean
it's we're talking about it right now
therefore it probably exists I don't
remember hearing this term 10 years ago
right so it's obviously there people are
getting fired and you know killing
themselves and [ __ ] so something's up
well it's we it's like if you well like
it's funny cuz even like with Ari
Shaffir you know it's always tweet and
already you know and it just came up
when teams yeah just saw somebody sent
me a link I don't know something just
happened today with it but um uh it was
like oh wow this guy is you know Ari's
getting can't he's like he's getting
cancelled in the in the sense of like I
think a lot of people who maybe didn't
even know about him yeah yeah yeah are
now just they hear his name and that
he's that it's no good that he's right
right you got a stigma you're done kind
of I think a lot of his fans who were
his fans for his dark and yes style and
his like totally graveyard sort of
Alfred Hitchcock kind of you know his
ambience yeah yeah ambience his shtick
or if they're they they are probably
they love it they have to be accepting
of it at least if they know that that's
what he's in yes yeah what was that what
was though there was a we had a video
question one of our listeners sent in
about this okay I haven't huge Tuesday
oh that's my pot and was just wondering
what Marx thought about the Kobe video
that Ari Shaffir did I know Theo von
said in his podcast that it was just a
whole mess of a situation and you know
children died did you know that there is
free speech but to expect you know the
wrath and consequences that will come
from that
and I'm just wondering what mark thought
since I know they're both good friends
and I know like re mark likes to push
the envelope to on his comedy and he's a
real mailman yeah
funny maybe should have just been a
Twitter drive I don't let me let me know
you guys think and please come to a peso
I the border loves you
I think the border loves you yeah yeah
gang Avenue thank you brother that's a
good it's nice that he listens to both
of our podcasts yeah that is nice
yep odds are big but if you really want
to know my are anything I just think who
gives a [ __ ] he's he's a he's a dirtbag
this is his thing
he's a friend of mine this is he's
always done this and for some reason
this Kobe won really hit home with
people and so he just he's always made
these kind of jokes when someone dies
but for some reason this one is sticking
yeah and I don't give a [ __ ] you know
he's not a bad guy that's something when
are he gives back he gives so much but
people just know him as this you know
friend dosing a Kobe joke making guy
with a lot of people will just the thing
about some of the cancer culture stuff
it's like you you get introduced to
people for the first time only is a bad
guy yes and I don't want to say any
names but somebody gave out his address
Wow and it's a person we know and you
want to be like hey [ __ ] what are
you doing like you didn't you're calm
you know what he's doing it's not trying
to get on other people's side by I know
you're angry but like also you're
introducing people to our ease joke
cause you're actually spreading it more
either you think it's so evil why would
you want more people to see it yeah you
know and and it's just so backwards and
giving out his address is basically what
he's doing to Kobe so now you're just
doing the thing he's doing so you're
just as guilty and just as big of a
piece of [ __ ] or maybe more because Lee
start was trying to be humorous I mean
he's a horrible comedian so he's not
gonna be funny
but at least he was trying he doesn't
he's not hurting anybody the guy's dead
but the other guy giving out the address
that could actually cause violence yeah
what if somebody shows up over there
yeah yeah and then then we should tweet
out your [ __ ] address how about that
yeah and then when does it end yeah yeah
you [ __ ] shoot yeah it's so funny
because Oryza nice like always let me
stay at his place I don't even know re
very well yes let me stay there for two
weeks when I was in needed a place to
stay in New York I mean that's a nice
thing to do
yeah he's not your thing stay in you
know you can stay in my place
I don't think he charged me any you know
didn't even make me pay anything right
what do you about the dose thing with
Bert because that really a lot of people
on the fence on on the big [ __ ] and then
that just pushed him over into the in
New Mexico
yeah I think I don't know enough about
the dosing but I just think as far as
like surprising somebody with some drugs
I think that's kind of sometimes I'm
like is that some of the world that they
all live in ah you know like I don't
know what their previous history with it
is if they're like you know slipping and
you know you know you know sprinkling
some you know some of that [ __ ] brain
glitter some PCP you know I don't know
what they're doing how much they're
secretly hide and acid in each other's
ass like when I was growing up they had
a thing for Japan for a while girls
didn't LSD in their vagina yeah a dick
trip you dick I'll go in and get all
burning man that was the thing yeah well
I think Earl was tripping you get in
there and get some of the trip is real I
don't mind a trip but I don't want it
through my dick hole that's that's a
weird suppose that's a wild entrance at
that front suppository hell Nick Nick's
a creeper well he's a premature baby
dude he's making up for lost
are you a preemie well you came out good
that's insane man why is a lot of these
guys going thirty-six and Nick got out
early broad nick is a hard worker oh
yeah I was like a c-section really oh
yeah I came up through the [ __ ] roof
oh wow I guess maybe this the moon room
I didn't come up through the door yeah I
could see if you like I don't know you
know is the best thoroughfare right see
what else is going on and you've all
touched your mom's veg f it but I
haven't touched my mom's vagina which
feels pretty good oh yeah I guess I
could see that uh yeah there is always a
weird element I think sometimes when I
look at my mom and she and I both know
it I did yeah yeah you ruined her labia
for a while and they say it goes back
yeah I hear it's never exactly the same
but that's my buddy said that oh well
maybe had a big kid or something yeah he
said cuz I thought we've all banged some
milfs and it didn't feel that different
yeah I don't have any feelings in my
penis at all I don't feel like oh come
on I don't think so I mean it also many
of the nerves were in my brain that's
how it's like if I think hard enough I
can feel something but otherwise it's
kind of like wait is you serious yeah
just not I mean yeah like I'm not very
sensitive downtown I don't think so I
don't what you got jizz it all over no
really
oh I put it in I'm done oh yeah I mean
and don't worry I got the brain stuff to
I'm going I hate myself I'm tiny I'm gay
all this [ __ ] yeah I don't have the you
got the band back together oh yeah oh
yeah my dicks like like a girl at seeing
the notebook
it's just weeping it's bad bro the first
time I ever had sex I remember getting
right up like literally my penis was
right outside of this girl's vagina yes
and it just like sneezed ejaculate just
like like it was yeah so it hit the out
so it pressure washe oh definitely it
was like it was almost like my he was
like I'm too sick to handle this vomited
outside of this girl's yeah entryway you
puked at the table you didn't get to the
buffet oh man your Golden Corral and we
were so ready everybody was so ready so
then I had to pretend like I was so
ready bro and that was crazy cuz I had
to like Oh hold on I don't want to just
do this yeah make up this long story
right and then I finally just got honest
with her and and she smelled like
cigarettes as well but mom aside then I
got honest with her and I said look
already I'm done yeah blue condom no con
oh oh so she didn't she didn't feel the
big splurge of mayo
she might have seemed I think I think
she was gonna be a nice cuz it kind of
you know out like right in the hallway
right I got in the 4-year ah yes you're
in the lobby yeah damn a lobby so I was
in the lobby ah hey killer so I gotta
say I've known you for 38 years now and
you're really getting more comfortable
as you the more every year that goes by
you're getting more at one with yourself
well thanks man and it's it's inspiring
thanks bro cuz you know in the beginning
of comedy we all kind of pretend like
we're cool and we're not nervous and we
don't give a [ __ ] but we're freaking out
the whole time oh yeah you know but now
I feel like you're owning you which is
very healthy
thanks man I'm trying to do better at it
it's definitely yeah it's been something
you know like I've been on that path or
like or not a path but you know I got
sober a couple years ago got into that
world and so that kind of stuff made me
start to like I don't know it's but it's
definitely helped me with try not to be
so like how you cease to be so much more
angry I'm still kind of edgy about
business and stuff oh yeah scared same
here but uh I don't know think about it
feel like they're taking advantage of me
yeah yeah dude but nice to be on stage
and always I felt like I had this thing
that like I had to prove or something
yeah yeah yeah it's been interesting man
but but that's interesting about
learning as we grow and growing in our
voice like when I watched you on on your
rogue and I was like oh my god dude this
guy is like such a just one just like
some I can't even tell what airy your
friend well I was I was nervous don't
get me wrong
oh dude totally right yeah you were oh
my you couldn't tell you were cool Zach
you well I think you channeled the
nerves into you and did like just beYOU
on steroids and like you popped you did
to a lot of people oh yeah the response
was great from you being on I had a good
response but you know I saw I got a ways
to go yeah I feel like you've honed a
thing and I'm still I'm still in the
path of honing I think but I think
you're such a but I think one does the
thing that we start to realize is that
yeah we're already kind of with maybe
where we need to be in some ways I mean
I think you're such a unique I mean
there's just nobody who's who's has the
same it's not only the jokes but it's
also you kind of your ambience meeting
up with this mmm this uncomfortable you
know I'm uncouple right now so really
really I feel like I'm so weird and
different I don't know it's all very
strange and we don't know what we're
doing but the journey is the fun part
we've got to stop and realize that you
know where we're gonna be 88 one day
we're gonna be like Mel Brooks and
[ __ ] Carl Reiner going those were
great times I wish we had stopped and
soaked it in a little do you think as
comics it's hard to enjoy stuff though
Oh completely you just worry about the
next thing you're always about the
future when's my next gig what's this
this is guy hate me I got I got a make
up with him that
girls yelling at me I got to work on
that but just think like remember back
at Lucy's yeah we were on the [ __ ]
yeah we did Lucy see how there's a bar
in New Orleans that had an upstairs show
yeah that's a great room for a great
room great room but I didn't know what
was going on I knew you had done some
stuff so that was exciting but now
you're in I'm in your studio and [ __ ]
in LA yeah we're both here it's quite a
roller coaster of anal I mean a lot is
happening yeah that's crazy
who's Nick serial IV [ __ ] water baby
we're glad to have you though I'm glad
your mom didn't get in the borscht yeah
that's true she thought about it
encouragement she was supposed to stop
every kid she schizophrenic oh I'm sorry
I didn't know oh it's all good making
all the jokes you want she's single Hey
all right I love a crazy bro yeah Markel
date one of her yeah yeah man well that
was so wild coming up and that time I
guess in New Orleans I don't know I felt
like you guys had like such a close-knit
group there and I didn't really kind of
fit in but i but i but i did start doing
comedy they're in Lucy's and uh
in brown that that little bar that was
downstairs next door across the street
oh yeah originally it had a sign on the
stage' said Brown on it yeah what was
that it's like a Wednesday night yeah
yeah yeah and the guys like we did make
any money tonight you just after him buy
drinks it's what he told me well oh [ __ ]
about like 19 drinks
two of them yeah yeah you had to pay to
perform when you when you were new yeah
because you were like you were in the
way like they're you're lucky we're
letting you do this here money's no
scene really oh no they're barely is now
but it's better but yeah stand up it
didn't even seem like a way to make a
living we're just like let me try this
it's something to do because all we did
was drink yeah and try to get laid and
drive around drunk and you know do blow
or whatever but like stab which is it
felt like let me try this thing I got
nothing going on yeah yeah girls don't
like me maybe this will be some way
women yeah and then my friends like I
move in New York and I say well I got
nothing else going on it almost kind of
helped being desk
and worthless and a loser yeah because
you had nothing attached to you and
you're like [ __ ] and I go to New York
City what's the difference yeah I can go
up there to Stacey yeah it's almost like
yeah what other reason yeah it's like
you almost have to be at this low space
in yourself yes okay oh I'll take
anything right right right right because
moving in New York I don't know that was
so scary I didn't do that
you didn't do it to LA AHA oh yeah I
knew I got mugged three times in a year
you know you're so poor you're so
worthless and you don't know the city
and it's before smartphones and my
landlord died of AIDS I got bedbugs I
mean the whole thing was bananas yeah
yeah yeah but you're just so young and
drunk the whole time you're like yeah
this is life I'm an adult
yeah oh you guys I feel like now that's
a different side where I think I would
understand you guys holding on to the
cult or more of comedy like the the you
know the sort of British regalia ah
right because you guys really go through
it there in New York like you're
sleeping on top of us you know yeah fat
guys back for $20 a night you sure
really
whereas in LA it's like you can even if
you're in the park here it's nice yeah
that's right the weather I do it I got
to tell you I'm pitching these shows
that'll never gets old and I'm at the
Fox lot and you walk in there's a big
parking lot it's a beautiful day
this is open-air courtyard all these
girls have their shoes kicked off they
get the feet up on the table there
they're smoking vape pens they're
drinking a coffee they got the
sunglasses on I'm like you don't know
what you got this is amazing you don't
appreciate out of any of it this is your
job you're getting paid probably 100
grand a year we're gonna @tv you're in
show business you got your shoes off at
work yeah you're living it living it
they don't even know they're like uber
eats is taking a while you like shut up
[ __ ] you're living the dream what are
you crazy
you got a Tesla yeah have a moped oh man
as it blows my mind but that's LA I mean
I get it I'm an idiot I'm the weirdo I
should have moved here because what
would you have but you could have done
it different yeah you're right you're
right you gotta go that way it's just
like you you just couldn't have done it
different like you couldn't have gotten
you gotta go with your gut like you got
to be in New York I mean you got your me
in like it had to be as you're growing
over there and has you're getting more
opportunities you're like holy [ __ ] like
because in LA it's like you see people
that are
I have a different type of talent than
you yes people that aren't ready that
don't have that a lot of times do not
have some talent sure and you see them
get huge opportunity right you know in
it and and everybody kind of backs it up
there's more of this PR kind of bull
yeah yeah la almost feels like a high
school extended you know it's like cool
clothes cool cars cool guy
sneakers halfa he wins he wins yeah yeah
we're in New York it's it feels more
like oh that was a clever take on that
joke and it was it feels more arty a
little bit like a little more
intellectually and like like Dave Attell
as I mentioned he looks like a hobo
right but he's this brilliant guy you
know he's a let yeah yeah you always
have somebody like that yeah anything
that makes you check that checks the all
the level yes it's like even if he's not
personally doing it it's just him being
there right there's a ceiling as to
what's going on yeah but then you go to
the Comi store I'm in the main room
green room and you're like look all
these sexy dudes you know like Brendan
shoves a [ __ ] chiseled fat [ __ ] like
he's got a slick hair the cool shoes got
a chain on I would never even think to
put on a change I think that white part
of bacon yeah on the white part a baker
still good but damn boy yeah yeah thick
and not good for you yeah he's a thick
crust
he's got the cheese in there too you
know you stretch it in it it pulls I
know I know
but he's like seven foot one he's got a
huge piece so badass it's crazy one leg
dude his other that it's a it's a
[ __ ] penis of the Neil he's got a
bendy dick yeah he's got ligaments oh
yeah he can stand on his dick yeah it's
a kickstand a dick Stan you know what's
amazing about Brendan man and uh because
he and I do the King in the same podcast
and it's like he's like to go from
football right to fighting mm-hmm which
you would never even imagine if you
talked to him that he was a UFC fighter
I feel I know he's so sweet yeah it's
like he's like he's kind of like that
American dream in a weird way of like
that if you work hard you can get you
can make things happen you know yeah
like he never stops working right you
know I'd say crazy he works so hard bro
it's crazy like he's he's
in the morning he's on that bike his
family's flying Oh Columbus this weekend
he's come back he's doing this podcast
he's doing that and he keeps a good
attitude yes positivity is very
underrated yeah yeah he's very positive
he looks good the whole time he's always
smiling you never see him like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] yeah and you're right he does work
and in that and that that vibe that he
has that's one of the things that I
think a younger generation with a comedy
how did they attract two more because
they don't they don't have this kind of
left like this to them it's all like
about it's more on fun yes let's have
fun it doesn't matter who we are what's
going on let's have a good time and
that's what he has yeah whereas some of
the old some of the others are like oh
man you know yeah yeah somebody you know
some of these this doldrum inside of me
and yes keeps me going not to mention
people watch the news all day it's none
of us shootings and death and politics
and Trump and all this [ __ ] coming at
you see when you see this fun-loving
happy-go-lucky guy you're like all right
it's like ah I feel a little better like
I can breathe a little then you know cuz
some guys you watch like Bill Byrne it's
just like dude I'll [ __ ] kill you
your mom's a [ __ ] and your dad's yeah
and all and you're like yeah I did it I
did exactly don't hurt me
you feel he's gonna give you a wedgie
yeah an easy job and you're like all
right it's like a it's like a golden
retriever
oh yeah he's kind of like a Chewbacca
yes I'm broken like a Claire's boutique
it will not leave no matter what
we're open 24 hours a day now yeah in a
two baka ran through a Armani Exchange
and [ __ ] stuck to him yeah he's a he's a
cool dude I'd sex with him today he's a
good egg he is a good egg like I did his
podcast once and this is the complete
contrast of New York I pull in it's a
sunny day he pulls in red Ferrari I see
one [ __ ] giant shoe of an Air Jordan
hit the concrete I'm like oh who's this
Tom Cruise you know and it's [ __ ] him
like you're a comic come on but it's a
different era yeah yeah he's in that I
don't know they just I wish sometimes
that I had like the clothing confidence
of like yeah the Lea and I know they're
so sexy God I'm just like
this fit this has never fit that's the
only thing I ever think when I put
something yeah maybe like we went to
public school yeah I got I have every
time I'm in a dressing room at like a
gap I put something on like a jean
jacket and I go hey this looks pretty
good and all I hear is eight friends
going what the [ __ ] do you think you're
doing you think you pull that off you
[ __ ] loser you piece of [ __ ] you kill
yourself I'm like all right there we go
that was a fun moment and you put that
[ __ ] right back on the hanger most of my
stuff is going out into the mic won't
you go out to the other mirrors outside
of your room yes yes and asking people
from a medium or a large and then just
[ __ ] I start sweating so bad and then
I go home yeah and you're all mirror
you're killing you're like John Travolta
your hair the [ __ ] blow dryer going
and then when you get outside you're
like what am i doing yeah this is what
this is wrong this is never this is
never worked but if you owned it people
would believe it but it's you it's in
you it's true the thing that doesn't fit
is in me man them yeah and the large
that's all in there the x ball that's
all going on inside of me right whether
it's a turtleneck or a [ __ ] sheepskin
vest you know it's all inside of me and
then that's why like ladies will
gravitate to some like ill-dressed
ill-fitting we're dogs it like he owns
it yeah that's the key isn't it yeah you
just gotta just got a they go wrong yeah
that guy's a tire jack is a hat but he
owns it he owns it baby that guy's got a
yarmulke on gross buddy oh yeah that
hair wallet that's what I do uh what did
you like did you like growing up in New
Orleans because you had a while it was
tough because I grew up outside of there
a lot of times people you know be like
oh you and mark Normand know each other
know mark and I know like you know I
remember different guys from their Wild
Bill that was oh yeah bill dykes
yeah bill dykes um who else to Scotland
green know there's he's funny
yeah really neat I haven't seen I know
yeah I know you've seen him on in New
York or yeah um and then number Patton
remember there was Neil slowly of course
Patton yeah Sean Patton
Fouchet Dayne funny yeah he was so nice
too
yeah that was back when like if you were
doing comedy back then you
loved comedy cuz now it's kind of hip
and it's a fad and everybody's like for
my new year's resolution I'll do
stand-up you're like I got out of here
yeah huge you don't like it yeah yeah
but we had we had to do it was like in
us you know we weren't any money but
yeah those guys all I looked up to all
you guys cuz you guys were a little
older you'd been on stage a few times
and I didn't know how to pull the mic
out like you forget that's all you have
to learn all that [ __ ] yeah you know and
I saw you you were so cool and collected
up there oh that's so funny I think I
had like I remember your bit still
aren't we all under the weather
yeah old dad I remember all of them yes
I didn't know how to write a joke so I
would just study and like oh that's what
you do oh that's pretty good okay and
then I would go up there and bomb I
don't think you bombed oh boy did I
bombed for four years I mean I had a
couple like you know you good Chuck it
was obvious that you were into it that I
was into it I was hooked yeah cuz I had
nothing going on and I'm and I was
jealous I thought you were like this
Jewish kid and I was like oh man look at
this Jung Joo gonna sneak over that in
New York and make it happen you know
some kind of nepotism just magic right
yeah yeah but good work Yiddish dust
yeah Breitling but no I'm not a probably
quarter yet you might have hidden yet I
got a little little something in me
about some Tiger Hidden Mark I think
yeah I got no foreskin that's for sure
okay yeah so that part of me is a little
jewy but I I wish I'm a big fan of the
Jews I love a Semite yeah well the funny
thing is about like a lot of Jewish
people it's like oh they act like
they're so good at everything
mmm and then they are mmm that's the
funny thing sometimes I think that's why
people hate them you gotta realize
there's six percent of the country and
they're killing everything they got the
media the banks lawyers doctors
accounting all that [ __ ] it's all Jews
yeah that uh percent but then also
there's a dark side of having a Jewish
buddy of you once spoon of bad yogurt
and you don't see him for you know oh
good point good point yeah yeah you give
one of our avocados gonna break out no
reaction it's true and I got the
allergies real bad yeah yeah you give a
[ __ ] half of a mango and he breaks
out into Christianity yeah I think you
just got some sand Christian wandering
right
not to mention Isis but yeah but it's
weird is Jerusalem it's all these
swarthy tan dark haired sexy beasts and
then you go to Brooklyn at some guy at a
diner going uh this says Darion and I'll
kill myself or whatever so it's a weird
a contradiction yeah totally yeah it's a
different the American Jew is different
I think than the yes Oh J yeah exactly
exactly
no J the original Jews everything Oh
Israel from Israel God I got I got I got
it at home the home team we didn't have
we did it when I was growing up we
didn't have any Jewish people around us
my mom dated a Jewish black guy for a
little while zolly Sammy Dave yeah Holly
Ritchie Holly Richburg yeah welcome to
our first Saints gamer gave he he got
his tickets to go to our first Saints
game there you go
but yeah we didn't they didn't have a
lot of that around they didn't have a
lot of that at least not in Covington
they yeah well I grew up in Treme and I
went to dilla Salle for high school Wow
the public schools are getting a little
rough yeah my dad's like you're go on a
private school was that Mintz de LaSalle
no it was co-ed thank God I think this
girl tell you that I used to date was
yes oh do it I was in love with her that
works I was so impressed that you pulled
that yes she was a beautiful girl man
yeah beautiful still what is she doing
now I'd love to get a look at a couple
of like a year ago
commuting her yeah um dinner I mean that
was back with like there's no hot girls
in New Orleans I'm sorry I grew up there
there's like six it's like the Britain
of uh yes yeah yeah they got some rough
gumbo mug it's not something's up down
there well it's just a lot of heat in
the food man in it yeah after the skin
it comes up through the pores to the
back that's right that's right it's a
lot of blotchy sweaty fat skanks down
there and I mean I love the people I'm
just saying you're not gonna find a Miss
New Orleans right you can't have a lady
that's had 9,000 oysters and she's
clocking it visually right right she
looks like a crawdad at that point you
know yeah heavy on the cross the real
boudin mug yeah there's like two and
they all leave you know they go to
[ __ ] Houston or something I don't
know where she and she worked at that
place Lucy's but uh she did yes she
worked it that's how I met her Wow
she was smokin man like she was a
humdinger yes she was home dinger
yes she was a nice girl she was really
cool we still communicate once in all
she got engaged a thing oh good for her
engaged and cool family and stuff boy we
talked my reinstated her house for a
while and I used to have this nervous
condition I would urinate in the sink
right ah and uh laying it on purpose
like you would put your dick in the sink
and pee it wouldn't go all the way in
but yeah we'd get up there okay okay
and I'm trying to visualize yeah no no
that's fine yeah yeah so I go in there
and when I was standard or folks house
that's how they the MA they busted me
this why have issues with cats man
because the cats would get over them
they would start peeing in the sink and
stuff to combat somebody else being in
the neighborhood a little territorial
yeah and so they're like they cornered
me one time at breakfast like you peeing
in the same well how did they know cuz
of the cats man well how did what the
cancer because I was the only rare I was
the rare Li was the unique element
outside yes you're the variable yes
interested like why would the caffeine
in the sink cuz something's being in the
same wow that's pretty good detective I
wouldn't I would have been like these
[ __ ] cats or I would every town shut
out Tarrytown detectives brother ha ha
ha
Terry knows a good place to get Nikes
and murder if you like yeah there was
one gated community but outside of it it
was hell I was very unused to wet the
bed oh yeah yeah dude it's one of the
ways I told you I went to bed forever is
that right oh man oh [ __ ] that'll give a
guy some character I'll tell you that
because you know you got a deal with it
you're like seven at a friend's house
they're all snoozing it's 4:00 in the
morning you go alright I gotta figure I
gotta have a game plan here I look at a
game plan yeah he's so sneaky
yes yes and it makes you realize like
lay this [ __ ] ain't fair but let's do
something about it you know you can't
just sit here and go what do I do
you know you got to start learn how to
use a washer/dryer I'm ever reading the
instructions inside the dryer door going
okay all right you know and flipping
sheets flipping mattresses I at one time
I peed the bed at my friend's house and
I was just covered in piss oh I slept in
my clothes covered in piss I have any
extra clothes so I had to go to summer
camp with him the next day covered in
piss wet the whole day and I finally
dried around lunch
time yeah but I just had to just not let
anybody touch me and I smelled like whiz
and and you know older people know
that's a crazy thing they new YMCA
summer camp like you woman like kickball
yeah I'm soaking wet I got a tie-dye
here but it's all whiz yeah but yeah
that was a rough day that was the worst
waking up at night at a friend's house
cuz you were already so scared to stay
at a friend's yeah so scared to go to
sleep
cuz the only thing I could think of
every night if I go to sleep am I gonna
wet the bed exactly and then how's it
gonna make me feel about myself it's
gonna be bad and then you wake up at a
friend's and it's literally like the
worst game show you've ever been yeah
you have to figure out how to dry the
sheet yep you know I remember having a
lamp one time in somebody's room and I
snuck over with the sheet and I just set
it over the line dry it to dry where the
heat was coming out of top of lamp and I
would move it over to so little at a
time that space I could smell the urine
yeah it's like [ __ ] survivor you
gotta like figure that's naked and
afraid you're wet and are you alright
yeah and you don't want their mom to
wake up even though some of the people's
moms probably would've been cool of
course you just didn't watch your buddy
really didn't know that way yes toughest
part I'm at one time I went to bed it
was like a big sleepover my friend of
this big house it was like eight of us
and I woke up and all eight friends were
around me standing looking down at me
with the mom and I went huh I looked
down covered in pee and they're all
staring at me and one of my friends goes
why do you do that and it just crushed
me you don't you're like nine you're
like I don't know it stopped looking at
me it was brutal and the moms like get
up get up like she was pissed like you
were my [ __ ] Sealy yeah so yeah that
was tough why don't you do that yeah
we're tough man and then it home did you
have to clean your own bed yet to clean
the bed off oh she's on it now sure I
would flip that mattress you know
constantly you'd have a covered mattress
now because I had it but it was too
disheartening every time you sit down
and sound like a bag of Fritos I gotta
just live with that I can't live with
the krinkle I'll just take the the
soaking wet match yeah I don't want to
hear this yeah it's like we're in some
people don't want you wear a diaper
cuz I'm [ __ ] not [ __ ] alright I'm
not wearing a diaper I'd rather be
covered in [ __ ] than wear a diaper I
can't do it dude that's what I say like
about bike helmets like I would read my
father die get hit by a car on a on a
bicycle yeah then see my father ever
come in
door wearing a bike down oh that helmets
a bad look just sitting up there the
plastic yarmulke never looks the same
right now
no brutal my dad one time my dad lost
his job and we're like oh [ __ ] you know
it's kind of like scary what's dad gonna
do how we gonna pay the bills I was
young and he came in one day with a
gumball machine over his shoulder and
we're like what are you doing dead he's
like hey you know gotta make ends meet
and I was like oh that's a gumball guy
he's the guy like setting up gumballs in
a Rite Aid and then taking the quarters
out like he was he was struggling yeah
and I was like oh this is like your role
model you know you know this guy he's
wearing a suit and everyday and driving
a nice car and then one day it's
carrying a [ __ ] gumball machine damn
with stickers in it and [ __ ] was it
embarrassing like did you did you have
embarrassment like bringing people over
to your place and stuff like oh yeah my
parents are real weirdos like my dad was
a bottomless a lot and the old Daffy
Duck oh wow yeah yeah well he didn't
know like my friends be home and so he'd
have a t-shirt on with no bottoms and
he'd be like excuse me there Larry and I
was like hey my dad and my mom eat weird
food so like we never had soda you know
we never had like Lunchables or gushers
or any that fun [ __ ] it was always like
Dee what is it Dee ha evaporating milk
it was over there a lot
we had like we'd never ranch dressing
but we had vinaigrette like in that
weird French bottle and it was all
stained and gross and yeah yeah my mom
was a weird chef foodie [ __ ] thing and
it was it was brutal Dan you know some
people are like dominos yeah we didn't
have any of that [ __ ] they're like
that's bad for you which I get now but
at the time you like order some pizza
hutt yeah it's you know it's also bad
for is having nothing yes like half a
radish in there come on
I'm not eating radish I'm eight you need
to be healthy I'm like I'll be anything
yeah yeah I know I know you know some
people I'd like Doritos oh you don't
have no we didn't do that all that [ __ ]
was like gold to me my mom was
definitely the same way she was very
health conscious yeah
but also like but also yes you wouldn't
get us like the the regular stuff that
all the other kids had and also I think
some of us kind of pricey you know yeah
so some of that came into play but yeah
man I'm
member it was always embarrassing this
stuff not only did my like everything
else feel felt embarrassing but the
stuff we had to eat yes same same and
kids are so cruel like why don't you
have soda yeah like I don't know like um
whatever you got so many cookies you got
so many snacks anything oh how about
school lunch I would have a grocery bag
like somebody want a lunchbox
I had a grocery bag with all kinds of
weird [ __ ] in it and a jar of chocolate
milk like a glass jar so it's cool at
the Greyhound station it was but my mom
would be like bring that jar back so I
was like alright so after lunch I'm the
guy with a jar purely one with the jar
my god I gotta get it home they thought
I had a kidney in there some [ __ ] it was
brutal I was looked like I had moonshine
on me
brutal Nick but so right here even just
hearing this it creates a world yes out
of you yeah so suddenly there's so many
more little elements to the world it's
like not only am I going to school today
but I have this weird lunch I have to
hide it I have to make everything look
cool you know suddenly you're creating
like all these levels to the world yes
and you're getting creative
yeah and you're getting create you're
talking fast what he have a jar then you
come up with [ __ ] and make a joke out of
it you spin the bottle or something you
grab a guy's ass just something to get
it off of you yeah
you're hiding you're sneaking around
yeah something to get it off of you yes
yes and then you develop this weird
thing we think everybody's paying
attention what you're doing yeah so you
have to always be performing because
right even when nobody's looking at you
you think everybody is yeah you always
are like trying to seem okay trying to
seem like this so then right there even
inadvertently you get used to being a
performer right without even your own
like so then it makes sense that when
there's an opportunity to perform
somewhere that it's inside of you why do
this because I'm in oddly doing this
forever
that's a great realization right thought
I heard a great quote about comedy the
reason people do stand-up is so you can
control why people laugh at you
hmm and I remember I heard that I'd hit
me cuz it's so true you don't want them
to laugh you for wetting the bed but you
wanted to laugh at you for what you pick
right you know and I think that's a big
part of stand-up yeah yeah yeah yeah I
want to be able to I have to I need to
have some way of controlling what you
think about me yes so many other things
in my life made me feel like I have no
control Oh
why these people are looking at me this
way or what's going on right right yeah
I like all that MA
like the weird [ __ ] your parents were
doing stuff that I had no controller I
live in this sentence exam was so
[ __ ] bizarre totally Tommy and I had
a transgender nanny I mean we'd all
kinds of weird yeah house teacher
thought I was [ __ ] when I was in my
third grade story I remember she gave an
awesome my mom had to like come in and
be like I swear to god he's not you know
then she was like why do you think he's
[ __ ] and she goes look at this paper
and it was you know we were little so it
was a page of instruments like drawing
like a flute guitar piano whatever and
the instructors were circle the
instruments and I circled them all and I
circled a saw like a handsaw and she's
like look he's got to be an idiot he
circled a saw but I saw a Marx Brothers
movie when I was like 7 where he played
a saw yeah and so I circled a song cause
in my mind like yeah that's music so
when I told my mom that she was like oh
thank God I was about to you know ship
you off to Indonesia and have you killed
yeah we thought you were an idiot so
that was a so you know it was thinking
outside the box was was risky back then
yeah yeah I remember I've told this
story before but had the first kid ever
met that had a stutter I thought it was
the best thing I'd ever heard I was like
oh my oh yeah who's this magic man right
now it's free entertainment yeah who's
this for hick in early Tiesto Oakenfold
yeah and and so I I I started having a
stutter because I thought it was so cool
isn't that interesting and then I got in
trouble for it at school there cuz you
were mocking they thought I was mocking
them like I'm not mocking him like you
don't understand I'm I think this is the
neatest thing ever and I love the kid it
was a nice kid named Doug and but they
answer that like it when they said yo
you can't do that right how's like I you
just don't see that there's other ways
to do exactly exactly and I get where
they're coming from
yeah they don't hurt the kid but they
didn't see your point of view and you
were had no maliciousness
right I don't have any maliciousness
right oh but it's yeah I don't know man
but growing up in Louisiana was uh it
was tough man I specially in my
neighborhood I don't know you seemed
kind of you had some whites and blacks
and it was kind of severe really it was
just kind of poor black and white but
yeah kind of suburban he just kind of
like not redneck yeah just kind of
oh and I'm not judging the people it was
just a blow poor environment sure sure
yeah in Treme I came in a man up over
there it was scary it was pretty scary
like I'm all fidgety because of that
[ __ ] in my house was robbed constantly
and my duplex no he had a mansion Wow
yeah my dad bought a mansion that was
dilapidated on Esplanade Avenue right by
the French Quarter and it used to be
like we heard that Ignatius Reilly well
I think if you really want to get into
it my dad had a real bad childhood and
he's like he always wanted to make some
of himself he never really did so then
he saw this mansion for cheap cheap
cheap because the neighborhood sucked it
didn't have plumbing was falling apart
there's holes in the walls broken
windows a mansion but it was a mansion
and we also had this BMW when I was a
kid had holes in the seats and was
rusted out but it was a BMW you know and
word rich something I call it oh yeah
yeah yeah so uh yeah it was a horrible
way to live because everybody thought we
were rich we were the white family in
the mansion and we moved in there like
all these people got to have money so we
got robbed constantly so my dad
installed this alarm system and it would
go where like go crazy at like 2:00 in
the morning I was like eight gone well
weird there's somebody in my living room
right now like somebody below me is
rifling through our [ __ ] and stealing
our TV or whatever and you're like he
could come up and rape me and have his
way with me and blow me at all this and
he'd put a nice negligee cup and doing
my nails and all that [ __ ] so it was a
skittish way to grow up like we'd come
home a lot and the door was is open and
very violating and just you never felt
comfortable never cuz you're like we get
robbed right now you know yeah yeah I
can I can't imagine that level of it you
know yeah like I think yeah I was like
scared a lot but that's uh I don't know
if we ever had that yeah coming home and
being robbed and like just knowing
somebody could be in your place I always
was scared that somebody was in our
place while I was going to bed at night
yeah yeah that we have to look
everywhere yes I have to open the
closets and I would hook these like
cables from one door to the next like
they couldn't open one door because it
would oh the door would stop it like
just all this crazy level of checks and
balances to just feel like okay yeah
good yeah cool well here's a bad when we
got robbed a bunch so we kept calling
the cops and eventually they were like
alright you guys keep calling us we're
just going to
take out in your kitchen overnight and
maybe we'll catch a guy so these two
cops plainclothes detectives came and we
met them and it was all exciting that a
daily belt gun and the badge on the belt
thing you know the whole thing and I was
like oh my god I couldn't sleep then I
was so excited I hope they catch think I
hope they beat the [ __ ] out of him and
tase them and all this [ __ ] and I'm just
laying in bed so excited I finally fall
asleep I wake up at like 6:00 in the
morning I run downstairs imagining that
they're gonna have guys in a headlock
and cuffed and put them in the car yeah
and I run downstairs they stayed in the
kitchen the whole night they ate
everything they ate all the food so we
got robbed again they had all the
[ __ ] Cheerios and the the made
pancakes cuz they got bored and they
just ate everything everything was gone
[ __ ] cops I know they took the
radishes on the chicken bones and all
that [ __ ] all the abandoned dude they're
under fun I guess I guess I don't know
that was part of the deal brutal brutal
yeah New Orleans was tough man it's a
tough town the scariest part was like
the face to face crime like my bike got
stolen many a time yeah and you know
these are big you know black man yes yes
you know they they puberty like for any
you know I think it's like a SAM
mustache going and all this and oh yeah
thank you really yeah yeah kid named
puberty Wilson had in our neighborhood
and this dude I mean was Jack oh yeah he
was born with a prison tattoo and right
right exactly
those weren't teardrops that was a
tattoo it was a different environment
yeah the racial environment down there
was just it was just black people had
nothing right right I mean nothing it
was hard to realize that at the time
yeah like now as I get older you see
like oh okay these people had they
didn't had that you know like there
wasn't any black doctors right nothing
not in that area that's for sure right
so you didn't have of course it would
have any role ma like it's gonna be very
you know like the the chain of like um
of pop like the level of poverty you get
into not just fiscally but then beyond
that where you get like emotional just
having right right yeah like I would get
my bike stolen I'd run home crying and I
go mom they stole my bunch you go there
they need it they did it I was like what
are you crazy but now I kind of get it
right but I will say as a white kid
growing
like the only white kid in that
neighborhood you're the minority right
you go outside the neighborhood you're
back as a white Prive white you know but
in that neighborhood EULA and it feels
bad be in the minority sucks it's not
like they can just go hey white boy and
you're like ah which is not even a
negative thing he's just I'm a boy who's
white but it still hurt because I was
different cuz you were different
yeah so I kind of I I don't to say I
relate to a lot of [ __ ] but you know I
get a label you can own well you've had
that experience where cuz that's the end
that's the end thing right just the I'm
different there's there's an easy way to
make me feel different yeah you know I'm
not wet yeah and then all the rest of it
piles on exactly there's more women on
earth than men but if one girl is at a
party with 50 dudes she's gonna feel
weird yeah you know so the minority is
is it's fluid you know we just talk
about minorities in majority and all
that but it it changes depending on your
environment yeah yeah it changes man and
I think yeah I feel like there's a lot I
feel like when I was growing up there
was probably a good bit of and racism
kind of felt both ways if you weren't a
racist person if you didn't really like
you know there were some people would
probably hated black people
yeah real adamant about it oh yeah you
know adapted to like old like kind of
you know uh I want to say red next
episode cuz it's redneck people that
aren't that way at all that's true but
there was a lot of people who didn't and
then if you interacted with black kids
and they were mean again this you're
like [ __ ] well what do I do like all
right right I don't want to have any ill
will but there's also these kids are
mean to me yes yes and they probably
didn't have anything else to do like
right if you think everywhere you go
it's like everybody has some but you
right exact can't imagine what that few
no I was hanging out with these two guys
martinet and Toni they were like my two
black friends and we were at the black
mall because I slept at their house we
went to their mall and the whole thing
and we're playing at the arcade in the
mall and one of my friends was doing
well at Street Fighter and I was like
yeah get up Toni kobata
and these two bigger black guys behind
me like puberty Wilson and testosterone
Jones we're like they're like doing the
white voice and oh I'd crushed me it
cried like go in the bathroom he like
all right take it easy that hurt you
know just go back out there
yeah my two friends were like don't
worry about those guys they're idiots
they're mean I was like yeah yeah but
you because you're already the outsider
and then you you're doing the white
voice and they called me on it oh it's
[ __ ] humiliating
I turned beet red it was brutal it's
hard it's hard being uh hard being white
focus it ain't easy
it's hard being so aware yes yes exactly
sometimes that I hate the most about
ignorance and I attribute a lot of it to
you know I think that's kind of what my
alcoholism is sometimes it's just this
heightened level of awareness and
sensitivity not just sensitive but
hypersensitive yeah and you want to shut
it down yeah they just want to starting
with anything to like please just
something make it so I just don't care
anymore
yes I don't care as much yeah because
you had because you care to let this
intense level of every constantly yeah
that it's exhausted you yes yes and you
have the couple drinks you're like ah
enjoy myself for ten minutes yeah I'm
with you like I like out for so long I
heard recently someone said um life's
not happening to you it's just life is
just happening oh and I'd always never
realized this wind of the world that I
always felt like was pushing against me
just this like life was happening to me
yeah uh everything's but life's just
happening right here and so then every
now and then that helps me feel a little
different like that got a question that
came in here
oh yes use me hey Mark APO mark it was
really good to see you come through
Springfield Missouri right before
Christmas when you played the Blue Room
hey it was a great show my wife and I
had a blast thank you for the people of
Springfield were good to you good a
question as to both of you I know you
guys both live on the coast and big
cities I was wondering if you've ever
considered moving away from LA in New
York to maybe set up roots in the
Midwest or the south to get away from
that big-city life style gang gang gang
bruh good question has you a question
what do you think I fantasize
when you bought a place I know like you
made money I mean I mean you started
making money I was jealous you when you
got to open up framing Schumer because
you were awesome money well that was a
sweet sweet ride I mean the Jets and she
would just hit that arena level so I was
making good money and getting treated
well and things I got I was pure luck
and what we have an ice cream at night
and never do it and she's a she's a big
pot friend yeah so it was just like so
much hotel room service and we had
movies and big screen and the weed and
the edibles and the anal and the [ __ ]
great great time she's a she gets a bad
rap but she's a giver yeah good egg you
know good hang you know her yeah you
know but I know people people have a
problem with her but you know they don't
know her I know her she's cool oh well I
mean I think yeah she law I think she
look for me I thought that and I would
talk about Amy you know I talked on the
phone maybe a couple weeks ago but I
felt like she was starting to maybe want
to even get more into politics I have no
truth about this but this is a
perception that I had right and she and
whenever Hillary did in one knee like I
think she was gonna not use Hillary use
that vibe but she you know she was in
that movement like yeah totally at it
she wanted probably to try and get into
politics then maybe I don't know yeah
that politics is the I never touch it
because it just splits the room and
that's a bad idea and we're comics like
right you look at Twitter now all the
comics are just going like we need to
change this and this is I'm activists
now and this is that you're like what
happened funny yeah I mean we are comics
all right you can have your opinion but
like let's make with the yucca muffs
chuckles you know here sometimes I get
so like worried about my own [ __ ] now
in cold rooms that sometimes I forget
though but I have to remind myself so no
you can't [ __ ] go in here every day
yeah puberty Wilson's coming out here
like it's all in yeah you can't help but
I felt like yeah that but um but I've
always thought that she's one of the
funniest people off of sage yeah yeah
that even watching her comin without
even taking that in the concert what I
mean quick quick at the table like she's
running circles around you're like damn
I gotta step it up yeah
and especially you like shoot I thought
that I was quick or something inside I
could do this but when you meet her it's
like Prefontaine it's just yes Wow she's
on some level that's a little beyond and
cutting to like she can say that thing
we're like oh I didn't know you knew
that [ __ ] you got me there damn you know
yeah fun stuff
yeah like yeah just I'm
I always say that she's her donnell
rawlings two of the funniest people that
oh really don't know he just makes me
laugh I mean he's a killer act I've
never really hung out with him
he's just so he's funny oh yeah yeah but
yeah man I thought was John's like man
this guy's living it up dude have an
ice-cream at night this dudes doing it
yeah I was doing it and plus I was
single then and like tinder was kind of
new ish and so I had an arena of labias
just like they can't bang her so I was
getting the the you know placenta run
off and I was I was hit and klitz like a
speed bag it was exciting
yeah yeah those are wild times yeah and
yeah we're in the four seasons and
shit's over a labia yeah yeah caught up
yeah I remember a couple of places I
caught up with you guys at I think
that's right where but we would you knew
we did Mahalia Jackson New Orleans and
we went to what's-her-face his house
after Jennifer Coolidge Coolidge's house
you were newly sober and I'm er being
like come on do this New Year's baby
you're like I can't Betty I'm sorry I
was like damn I lost the oh but it was
for the best I get it yeah it was for
something man yeah it was good see
that's the dangerous thing is the
problem with booze and xanax and coke
and all that is it it feels right so you
don't want to quit but the best thing to
do is quit because you need it so bad
that you got to not learn how to not
need it you know you gotta if it feels
so good so you're like oh them drinking
is what I should be doing right now but
that's exactly why you shouldn't be
drinking you got to learn how to
overcome it without it right it's a it's
definitely a trick yes it's a trick it's
a trick my my therapist I'm always like
just give me some xanax give me a
[ __ ] valium or whatever a
prescription he's like let's beat it
let's just try to beat the anxiety
instead of just trying to like medicate
it away yeah yeah oh sometimes I wish I
had me as an her you know I'm what first
time a guy gave me a soma this
homosexual of a song gave me a soma man
build this got Billy conforto and our IP
passed away he was from Laplace uh I
know the type and uh he was homosexual
but also a prizefighter why yeah right
but it could've been your babysitter did
you know that's black guy oh no whoa
okay white enough all right all right
all white prizefighters always fun
that's one for the for the home team but
he gave me a soma dude and a half hour
later I just turned to my cars on a
highway and just took a
straight-up [ __ ] right turn and we're
lucky we're alive sometimes Louisiana
livin was was heavy it is heavy these a
lot of we stock because it's boat people
are like yeah yeah that's right well
[ __ ] up let's get in this boat yeah
that's right surround my water and
Gators and dose
yeah ghosts who do out there it's no
joke we had a kid this boy Andy and he
uh he goes for chase him or something he
was dealing with him and he end up
taking his own life
there you go they had a bunch of friends
died of heroin Bunch friends I have
methadone growing up bunch of drunk
driving some of the best heroin recipes
you've ever had oh yeah yeah Wow put
some hot sausage in that air Owen yeah
heavy dude put a little bug in Tony
satton that need oh baby Lowell BAE you
can't get that all that leaf wow yeah I
would just went down back home to see my
folks in a boy I really ate it up did
you oh yeah are they pretty really proud
of you know they must really have some a
lot of pride you know it's weird is they
don't really say much but then I talked
to it like I'll meet one of their
friends they're like your mom never
shuts up about him like really should
tell me no but I'll take it
I'll take it yeah but I think we're just
uh we're cold people the Normans yeah I
try to break through I'm I'm a
touchy-feely douche but uh there it's
very they're military they're like you
know stiff upper-lip kind of Wow
yeah my dad this idea of a hug there's
give you a tap on the shoulder and
you're like oh [ __ ] thanks dad Wow
what is it my birthday you know but it's
not not a lot of yeah
connecting yeah yeah that connection man
it's wild yeah I'm learning that oh
that's all new I'm 36 so I'm gonna die
soon so I'm trying to like do it myself
and push it on him and are you having
sex and stuff now or what do you do I
got a hot lady are you oh yeah I got a
hot lady at the house in New York and
yeah she's she's like a normal person I
mean she's got everybody's got problems
but she's like she met my parents
and she's like whew that was tough like
you meet my parents you feel like you're
bombing yeah they're tough like you'll
just say a whole thing and they'll go
like the
won't respond yeah I talked to dr. Drew
about he said my mom has still face
which is this like thing that moms have
that makes babies cry and [ __ ] cuz
they're not giving you any reaction Oh
why'd you stand but I need a reaction
yeah I need something yeah something I
just need some some I need to know that
things are okay yes yes and with them
you have no idea where you're at what
are you mad am i mad at what's going on
do you hate me am i adopted where are we
yeah so Wow that's some of the stuff
that leads us to just to our behavior
and what we do you know yeah that's the
beautiful lady right there she is yes
what's the name diamond where'd you get
that house guest made it up she's
[Music]
diamond LaRue
she's a real diamond though yeah and
diamond in the rough oh that's awesome
man good egg Cape Cod ladies for a while
in New England they're well off on she
well off not really you'd think right
yeah haben cape huh yeah yeah yeah a lot
of cod uh-huh Oh hate to interrupt you
guys
it's the only ad in this episode and I
got to ask what if you could make your
work take less work well you can with
kaptara kaptara
it helps you find the right business
software for your needs fast so you can
get back to business even faster
compared thousands of software options
read reviews and instantly narrow your
favorites you'll have more time in no
time you can find the right software for
you and your business right now at cap
Tara calm that's CA p ter are a.com
slash theo it's the leading free online
resource to help you find the best
software solutions for your business
search more than 700 specific categories
of software everything from project
management to email marketing to yoga
studio management software sometimes
you're in a place with your business and
you you want to be in another place
instead of using all your time doing all
of these things
let us software do it for you visit
kaptara comm slash theo for free today
to find the tools to make an informed
software decision
your business Capt erra dot-com / Theo
it can be scheduling shipping it can be
well I have these different drivers who
are working for my my transport company
how do I get them all on the same
timeline and and make sure that they're
not working at the exact same moments
all types of ways all types of software
all for your business that's right go to
kaptara comm / CEO capt e RR a.com slash
th EO kaptara
software selection simplified and now
back to the episode let's get another
question that came in man alright wait
let me get this before we do it what do
you think how do you think it plays out
with uh with re with everything that's
happened because last night it said on
that article that people they didn't
have the show because they were afraid
people called into the car club I heard
they had to shut the show down and a lot
of those calls dude look I've made calls
like that that's nothing that nobody's
really gonna show up yeah I actually
called the club but yeah I don't live in
a show-up world anymore we definitely
live in a phone call world this is all
gonna go I mean it's a it's a hot thing
for this week and by Monday we won't
even think about it agreed
yeah agreed but do you so what do you
think how do you think he comes through
I know he put up a really nice message I
mean his message was it was real true to
who he was even at the end where he says
[ __ ] the Lakers you know dude right yes
yeah I did I liked it I mean obviously
his publicist or manager made him do it
because I know Ari and he's not this guy
but he kind of made it his own and all
that like when Shane Gillis had to put
one of these out we all made fun of him
because it was so publicist II you know
like it didn't have him in it at all
yeah and like he told us what he wanted
to say and it was way funnier but uh
yeah you got to do this [ __ ] I guess you
know we're trying to have careers but I
think it'll ultimately help him it just
seals cements his brand right you are
that villain you are that rabble rouser
yeah you know and there's and and yeah
it's okay to have that like yeah that's
the thing it's like I just want I'm
trying to think of a person that could
compare him to in the past it's not like
an Alfred Hitchcock but like you know
someone who's just like mischievous like
a Dennis the Menace II he's almost like
a Bart sim
you know like he's he's agitating he's
poking you and [ __ ] and you're like
alright alright but that's just who we
get that's his shtick yeah you know it's
and it works for him he sells out and I
hang out with Ari we walk down the
street Bakari yeah people people
likeable people love him he's been on
here and people really really enjoyed it
I mean that's the thing he's yeah it's
just who he is it just kind of felt it
just was a really it's just like I'm
almost like the Andrea Gail a bad chef
right right of bad moments yes at once
you know well we got weird priorities
like Chris Brown beat the [ __ ] out of a
lady and we've got a documentary out and
people think he's hot and sexy and then
I already made a joke and he's evil yeah
like I think Chris Brown is worse than
Ari but Chris Brown's doing the moonwalk
somewhere right you know so we got weird
we're all whacked out well team also and
you I mean some of this I think TMZ uses
a lot I mean it's definitely turned into
more of like a WorldStarHipHop kind of
yes it's gotten a lot more of like
scandal yeah and a more you know urban
black Oh an American whatever you want
to say I think so oh really I think a
lot of their stuff is these days and
some of that I'm like are these are is
this is TMZ just like using the black
like is it creating this other this
cycle of like interest behavior
sometimes or contributing to a cycle of
behavior influencing a cycle of behavior
you know it's like not like I don't buy
a lot of cultural appropriation [ __ ] but
I do sometimes like I got some ones that
show catfish I just feel like it takes
advantage of like a little now to use
the Internet oh I never thought about
that or like kind of Monopoly you know
yeah the wording is but like well I I
just feel like TV and showbiz they just
go where the money's at they go where
the bread is buttered so if that's the
way it goes like McDonald's for some
reason went straight black people in the
commercial you know used to be like
McDonald's gonna make fish and it was
like some fat white guy there's a white
manager yeah yeah now it's like hey
puberty get in here you know like yeah I
don't really make rear backer and right
yeah that hot apple pie is ready for you
there
Quincy but yeah I feel like you just
kind of go oh that's that's who's buying
the [ __ ] McDouble let's do that so I
don't know I don't know about the taken
advantage of maybe I never ever yeah
baby maybe that's just some weird thing
that it's probably some weird hang-up
that I have you know that might not even
be true
but you're right there sometimes I think
that Hollywood like leads us in a
direction but the more I learned
Hollywood just follows where the money
yes they're clueless they don't know
what I mean think about all the funny
comedians you know who aren't doing that
great yeah because we gotta have this
hot guy - or whatever the [ __ ] you know
this guy's yeah they're selling tickets
so they don't care they're not they they
pretend to like Pryor and Carl and but
they don't give a [ __ ] right they just
worry you know there's worried about
who's making money and that's their job
there were in suits their finance guys
who say hey I like Ali Wong they just
know the right thing I love Carmichael
he's the coolest but they don't know
yeah yeah yeah they don't know yeah it's
it's so it's uh because sometimes I give
them this bigger power right same same
we look I look them in as please accept
me yeah please give me a show I love you
you're my dad you know you're just crazy
because that's kind of one of the sought
one of the side effects of coming out of
like a you know the type of childhood
you come out of it's tough to be a
comedian is that then whenever you get
to a place and somebody's offering you
some you you're so please accept me yes
and that like kind of goes over into the
business sense yeah it's completely
really cost you um yeah this can cost
you ownership of things and you know it
can really kind of have you selling out
before you even know what's going on
exactly just wants so badly to be accept
accepted because think about it look at
all it first is like you do it a couple
of Mike some guys do my show Oh God
except yeah then you get Montreal I got
Montreal it's not even about Montreal
you just want to be you want to be
invited the party but you don't actually
want to go you just want the invite yeah
you know and that's the whole show but I
got a special me everybody I got one you
know just me me me I feel better I'm
accepted I'm in the club yeah I'm okay
I'm okay
but the real okay is guys like Schultz
who go blow me industry I'm doing this
on the gram yeah and I'm if you go on
any you know pitch meeting go I got this
guy fashion who does this right by the
camera there
how's that gonna make any money what's
the hook we need more diversity what are
you doing then he's gonna be like a
[ __ ] I'll do it on my own and people
love it yeah so that's the thing they
don't know but we act like they know
that they have no idea we're the ones
with talent right they stink yeah we
forget that sometimes yeah
they got nothing they just go where the
heat is yeah yeah it's interesting man I
like hearing that dude let's get a
question that came in right here that
Nick's got before we get to the question
I saw this was interesting we've talked
about doctah bounty hunter a couple
times on this show he recently got in
engaged to one of best friends or he
proposed
yikes I didn't see it can we play the
video yeah I heard about this he just
followed me the other day on no
Instagram
oh that's excited so excited actually
everybody tweet dog and tell him we want
him on this past week sweet him and
Instagram him send him messages that
would be huge I would love to have him
man oh yeah it really relates him in a
lot of ways he feels like a genuine dude
[Music]
he's right now
remain sure will you marry me
oh that's good TV a couple who see any
lovin you old bro oh I know that guy
works at the gas station by my house
we're not even joking the second guy's a
real girl
yeah looks like DJ Khaled did but also
another one go back a little more Nick
right there oh yeah he does he looks
like a bad job yeah he does dude yeah
job job yeah it looks like yeah it looks
like DJ needs a salad that's how he
looks like but it says in the article
they had been dating for weeks and it
was pissing off the daughters but at the
end it says he never actually gave her
the ring and then evidently there is no
engagement but it's still a little messy
situation there she is and they're in
the wedding photo with Beth you can see
she's the number 2 number 2 best best
best bridesmaid maybe it should've Honor
he needs like I need some help you know
I got a mourning my wife here and this
is the closest thing and maybe it's just
like a psychological move he really
loved that woman I mean it must really
be in love to be working with someone
have a grenade I mean the grenade they
had everything yeah it's constantly
working with somebody I mean that was
his life partner right there and working
in like tents like boot camp and via got
people in a headlock and she's holding
their legs and he's kicking like that'll
really bond a couple of weirdos yeah and
he's sober I think to hiepro I think he
does a lot of recovery stuff oh yeah he
does a lot of stuff like supporting the
military yeah he seems like a good egg
yeah man I I could imagine look
especially you're getting older you've
like sometimes you have a wife you have
a girlfriend and there's somebody else
that you care about it's like that kind
of stuff never it may dissipate because
obviously you have to focus on your
marriage and stuff yeah maybe he just
cared about this lady for a long time
and wanting to go yeah I'm sure he needs
somebody right now and he probably
doesn't know a lot of people he's an odd
dude so I'm sure he's got like a
community he kind of hangs with so boom
I'll just go to the next lady I'm not
saying it's right I'm just saying yeah I
mean it makes perfect sense yes yes if
she's friends with Beth then she's
probably got similar personality he
feels some comfort in her yeah well said
may and I uh yeah I don't know it'd be
nice to have him on I can't imagine
losing like your spouse but then I think
some guys they lose they luckily lose
their wife and like oh look out yeah
well there's also guys who go too far
and they go throw a little left what do
you call that stuff
arsenic not ours leander antifreeze
Villani freeze in the in the oatmeal and
to freeze Annie yeah and it'll be a ice
cold in a minute what else we got Nick
oh here's me that was like you and Joe
list [ __ ] yeah looks like me and Mike
Kaplan yeah yeah hey guys this questions
for mark mark I always see on Instagram
you riding around on the that moped of
yours through the streets of New York I
was wondering if are you known as like
the moped master you have any good
stories to share
kangay yeah burn up a pic of that there
Nick it's on my instant bring up that
ped you gotta see this hog of mine it's
a [ __ ] beauty
oh no she's nice oh that's sorry this is
your friend Nikki she's a pig hold on
where's there it is look at that thing
come on right through New York on that
yeah that thing's badass it's it's 86
miles of the gallon it's light it's easy
it goes about 33 miles an hour top speed
I'm in the bike lane I'm in the regular
lane I'm all over the road in that thing
I get in spot to spot that's legal oh
yeah I mean I got a toad once and I had
to register it and all that and I gotta
buy a helmet oh yeah but it's a it's a
real fun piece huh that was a fun little
journey when I got towed you would
listen I I yeah and your story yeah yeah
he documented going to get it and stuff
hey that's beautiful man right cost
about half the bike cost and it took me
like a week and a half but I got it out
and what are the cons of having that in
New York City a lot of cons that's the
thing a you gotta lock it up and people
want to steal it people want it my
neighbor's hate it because it's on the
sidewalk and I got a cover on it and
like it's so ugly so they're giving me
dirty looks the winner you can't ride it
so she's got to sit there and get snowed
on and [ __ ] it doesn't start all
sometimes just doesn't start yeah so
there's all kinds of problems with it
but it's a gorilla huh
oh yeah 1986
Aurelia I have Italian guys stop me
going ahead words when I was a kid Oh my
wife's a gun she can't cook in all this
[ __ ] and I'm like a thank you [ __ ] but
uh I get a lot of that so that's a it's
a rare bike apparently go in Craigslist
I just happen to find a fun one
God man yeah it looks so amazing now out
here do you think it would be better to
have maybe but this is so sprawling I
can't get on the 405 with that Chooch
that would be terrifying it'd be epic if
you did as well yeah I pull a Dean
Delray and flip over a car hood yeah
beautiful you got have you been in some
pretty bad accidents not one yet not one
hmm so when you think about when you
think about like doing like another
special or something I just shot one
last night you did yeah we'll see I mean
I just did on my own because I it Oh
awesome so we'll see what happens I know
you think so
I guess you'll try and sell it and then
if not maybe we'll put the clips out
exactly yeah that's awesome so where
we're at now I've been doing the hour
for a while now and it's getting
embarrassing you need to go back to San
Francisco like we saw this last year
yeah so I'm like I got to drop it and
write new [ __ ] but nobody wants it I
kept waiting for someone to buy it but
nobody would give me an offer so I said
[ __ ] we'll shoot it that's crazy yeah
yeah well it's a weird times you know
yeah where'd you do it dynasty
typewriter we sold out two shows we said
[ __ ] it it's a theater it'll look good
Sandler did his there oh wow yeah so
that's the new club that's downtown Los
Angeles yeah yeah right Sam's Club yes
the Haworth is the name of the theater
and really cool really sweet cute little
theater and it went great we got two
shows out of it and it's in the can
right now I gotta edit it oh here we go
here's the guy right here hey what's up
Theo what's up mark my name is Nick I'm
coming at you from Aurora Illinois the
snowy Midwest here it's really freezing
right now but I had a question for the
both of you actually
Thea you talked a lot about on your show
and you have a lot of listeners calling
about like
anxiety and how to deal with in stuff
and my question for both of you was how
do you guys deal with the anxieties that
you may or may not have but continue to
still do your work and killing mark I've
seen you perform here in Chicago and and
you're amazing I watch all your guys's
YouTube videos and I'm a huge fan and so
I'm just curious how you guys can keep
it consistent and still continue to do
so well in your field I don't want to be
a comedian myself but how do I apply
that to what I want to do and who I want
to be so that's my question I hope you
guys have a great day gang game game bro
what a sweet message huh
sexy hair I wish I had those locks I
mean he's doing fine if you ask me yeah
he looks like Thor I don't bang anxiety
if I had that dude Who am I gonna bang
yeah he's got a reverse widow's to look
at that thing it's going the other way
Oh beautiful man great looking eyeballs
and a sexy Lorenzo lawmen half of the
women that I've dated yeah yeah no doubt
about it those eyebrows I leap on them
dude I want to [ __ ] a night in
Casablanca huh oh yeah oh he's hot my
god dude any more information about this
guy yes his address god I don't want to
condition this guy's hair with my
[ __ ] body sweat no I want Superman on
top of me dude I want a [ __ ] man I
was gonna lay in his arms and say Clark
can't you no no Clark can yeah okay this
has got nothing sorry sorry it's a good
question man about anxiety yeah yeah
it's tough but I I go the other way
cuz he's like how do you deal with
anxiety I think you got a the more you
do the less anxiety you have yeah so if
you get over that hump of fear and doubt
then the anxiety kind of goes away like
I get scared to do stand-up well that's
why I do it right and then you get up
there and it goes away so once you just
do it if you think about it how am I
gonna do it how's it gonna go that's
when the anxiety kicks in just do the
[ __ ] thing go do the open mic go ask
the girl out go do whatever oh it's so
true and then the interesting thing for
me is I may even hear you talk about
that that anxiety
if not that when I don't do something
and I just have the anxiety then it
turns into a little bit of shame for me
yeah oh dude the guilt yeah I totally
have had you know a shame or a guilt but
yeah you're so right it's like geez guys
helping black kids in Africa oh it's
beautiful or South America Jesus who is
this hunk yeah you got nothing to be
anxious about man Nick manifesto Nick
this guy menace
yo man Nessie oh this Nicholas Menace
co-state he looks Greek on it might be
great man yeah he's like it looks like
an eagle Montoya prepared a you get in
the light man Wow
dude I think if you show your Instagram
to a woman you have nothing to be
anxious about but it just goes to show
you man this guy can look like a Greek
god and a demigod probably and you're
inside you're all [ __ ] up yeah so then
what is it called
but that's right there you're right
though I think it's just that contrary
action you know and that's something
that they talk about in a 12-step stuff
a lot it's just like yeah it's thinking
about things laying in bed when you wake
up laying in bed worst thing you can do
because it's just this isolation
isolation grows on itself
you know you think like oh I'm scared to
be around people and then you think that
you're by yourself for a couple days and
then you are then you are scared exactly
exactly yeah just go out and actually
take some action
yes contrary action it's like I don't
want to go for a run I'll go for a run
right now yeah I don't want somebody
invited me to the movie I don't want to
go I'm gonna go even though I don't want
to yes yes and then that that uncomfort
starts to go away dissipate and usually
you go oh this movie is great I'm so
glad I came yeah this wasn't so bad yeah
but if you don't go you're gonna really
hate yourself yep and then it gets
easier over time you don't have as much
of that anxiety yeah this it's not we we
work anxiety I think it's just this
we're supposed to be like in motion and
I think some of it is just this
stagnating this coldest sacking of us
being doing stuff and connecting with
each other that energy had been alive
for so long and now it just has no place
to go right right I think kind of were
wired as humans if evolutionarily you
farm you get up you fight a bear you
have you [ __ ] your wife you raise your
kids your farm you kill a bear you know
we have to survive we don't have to do
that
we got uber eats we got the granola bars
yeah so it's still in us so I think
that's why we're more anxious than ever
yeah you know because used to just go to
a factory you go home you crack a beer
you watch the football game you go to
bed you go to the factory you don't have
to do that [ __ ] even we're doing a pod
this is we're working right this is work
and then we're gonna go to the comedy
store and that's work yeah you know so
we don't have any struggle
you haven't have any struggle we don't
have a lot of a ton of human interaction
that yeah yeah but also there's a guy
recently he's talking to me about that
we don't touch the earth as much as we
oh oh that's good no this energy of like
the energy is supposed to usually come
in and out of the ground and into our
bodies and like that's good it doesn't
happen that much Whitney and our podcast
talked about this practice that's
getting popular because of that called
grounding and it's just going barefoot
and walking in the dirt and going on
hikes but barefoot because that whole
thing I mean the moped what you know
everything my body's like what are you
doing what do you do you have a midlife
crisis why are you buying this what do
you think you're a cool dude
and I get on that thing and it's
visceral I got the wind in my hair I can
feel the throttle I can feel the engine
heating up and my [ __ ] and everything
in the bumps and I'm Michael it's
poppin' and it's just great and I'm
leaving outside of cars it's
nerve-racking and I get to the spot and
I kind of go whoa I gotta take a minute
that was wild yeah you know I'm going
down Broadway in the best city in the
world and it's great the lights are
going by me I got a Chinese guy you know
passing me up I give him a honk he
doesn't wave back yeah and it's crazy
and then I just get there I'm like well
I would have been on the subway with
earbuds in just sitting there looking at
some hobo you know like it you got to
get up and get out and do something
that's why I like woodworking is good or
like that's why these guys who Tough
Mudder and [ __ ] tough mudders just like
I got a I got this body full of muscles
and organs I gotta use it yeah you know
I gotta push myself you get out of try
you got a try cuz it's easy to not try
it's so easy Jesus is here you know
we're creating them yeah we've
definitely created Society in America
where it's easy it's like yeah just
discomfort yeah everything's turning it
into a couch exactly and then boy when
VR gets in here it's over we're gonna
just VR a set and we go alright I killed
I'd have to leave the house you know
yeah people buy tickets and watch you on
in the virtual reality exactly and
that'll be it you're not gonna meet any
women you're gonna [ __ ] VR women and
it's gonna be over you'll just be
basically a passageway that food goes
through yes yes you're just [ __ ] and
eating [ __ ] and eating it's gonna be
crazy man yeah I mean look at what
people can account Leigh watch an MMA
fight you're like that's unbelievable
that two guys can do that or two women
can do that yeah I could never do that
but the human body is capable of such
you see a guy on a snowboard do 80 flips
and land you're like I'm eating Cheetos
and fingering myself yeah dude yeah and
not even washing my hands between now my
[ __ ] is yellow and orange I got all
the dust on I remember Chester cheeto of
course I do um I saw Kelvin Gastelum
last night at the store I saw in your
Instagram the fighter yeah he's really
on yeah one of the fighters EF fighter
of the eye and I got to be at that fight
I'd only been in one fight Joe of Joe
Rogan took me to a fight one time and
dude it was the craziest fight I was
with you you were there Atlanta yeah
yeah I remember we walked into his
cheeto me and you and we walked to the
arena and everybody went nuts for you oh
do you remember that and then I think
Poirier was yep or yeah yeah you were
there I remember Andrew was there I feel
so bad we hung out all day at the four
seasons and I remember after he won you
guys like hugs I was like whoa do is big
Oh blue my mind yeah it made me feel
excited that's pretty exciting handle it
very well
oh [ __ ] hey how you doing you know but
you you you look cool oh cool man thanks
yeah dude that's the first time I saw
those guys just go through it so much
yeah and just walk through that tunnel
with Rogan let you know that oh yeah
that really with a button-down on you're
like what the [ __ ] and he just sits down
puts the headphones on he's like heat I
don't want to laugh he cracked him in
the jaw like whoa where am I it was
sweat and AIDS is on you and [ __ ] and
Cheetos looking at a hot chick it was a
wild day that was a hell of a day
that's crazy I feel so bad that I forgot
the do you remember now is it coming
back got it all damn I gotta make some I
gotta say the n-word or something it
could stand out a little oh yeah if you
two roading down the n-word on his
favorite past it - well I remember that
I'll be doing that after the show tell
you that
who's the sober one between you I have
four beers in me that night I remember
I had a big gulp the whole time a beer I
was probably nervous something about
that old environment made me nervous oh
I get it I got me got Rogan we're in a
[ __ ] SUV with Rogan remember that
that was terrifying were you really
there you just messing with me I was
there remember you came in with a teen
shopping bags member you were like I
went shopping and we chatted for like an
hour and then they came downstairs then
we all went together oh yeah we sat next
to each other at the fight that was
elbowing you and I remember I said some
things you really hate take it easy man
I was being too offensive I think oh
yeah yeah yeah exactly I was making bad
jokes at the fighters like come on you
[ __ ] that's all you got your mom's a
[ __ ] you know I was just trying to get
into it and you were like shut the [ __ ]
up China I went for yay I was I wasn't
there and I remember Santino had to
leave early because he had a show in
Atlanta that night leave early yeah I
left early missed all the good [ __ ] yeah
I saw Korea but I missed that asagna
yeah man that was such yeah buddy yeah
it was just wild to see that guy last
night I think he's one of the best of
all time I think he's like a special
fighter he's different
who honest on you yeah oh yeah I didn't
see him I mean just gasps a limb but
yeah honest I mean that fight was just
crazy watching those two men hit each
other forever oh yeah God wow man that
was like the best day of my life and to
you that was a blip in there in your
mullet lifestyle yeah nobody ever leave
early we're all like damn he has to
leave early to go suck you read all the
skulls go yeah and it was brew dogs I
don't to leave I'd rather watch this
[ __ ] fight and go to the show but it was
fun it sold out good time I would try to
get us tickets to another fight man and
you know go that's do it that'd be
awesome
well fairly we really bonded to on that
couch Jase I gotta be more memorable no
I just probably just I was probably
thinking about myself
sure who is this couple of whites right
here what is this Segura and Rickles
who's that no I think that's Segura yeah
who does that look like who's that guy
Ebert maybe an old Shoob who's the guy
the store opens it up alan arkin no
what's that guys no yeah
our Marcus Hamilton Argus Hamilton yeah
right good on him
named after obviously a couple of slaves
let's be honest oh yeah oh yeah yeah
good play
what's up Theo and gang the sub dark
we're a couple of Tuesday's all right I
know about your best night and your
worst night performing comedy mmm I got
that for you thank you cute couple right
there yeah thank you guys
yeah you want to start Oh Oh tears man
all right well I've had a lot of great
nights I've had a lot of bad nights it's
hard to pick the top but I did the the
what is that
what's the arena here staples no no no
forum I did the forum once and that was
pretty unbelievers Schumer I don't know
what is that 30,000 people or whatever
the [ __ ] it is Lee 20 22 maybe 22 yeah
it was unreal and it's in a circle and
just rocked it and it just everything
clicked I did the Patrice O'Neal benefit
and that was a good one with Bill burr
invited me which was like such an honor
and that just clicked I had a gun I went
third which is like the best spot in
this show and just kicked kicked it
right in the teeth and it just you know
when your timing is it the laughs and
then you then the lad just worked um and
bill said some nice things after so that
was great but the worst probably two
months ago during Christmas I did a good
bunch of corporate gigs do you do
corporates I just did one this week
actually oh nice they're pretty they're
pretty different yeah they're not really
stand-up you just kind of like trying to
keep these people happy and get your
paycheck and get out of there yeah you
don't want to get any HR issues yeah yes
and I that's exactly what I did I had to
host a pharmaceutical award show big
hotel ballroom you know like white
tablecloths fine china tuxedos
chandeliers and I'm host I got note
cards like a stack that's high of like
next up best sleep aid here the nominees
like I was that guy I had a podium and
everything and I had to study it and the
paycheck was insane they picked me up in
a limo drove me out to Philadelphia I
get there I'm supposed to do 15 minutes
of
they end up to open just to like get
them loose and then go into the award
shows clean but they knew my stuff they
watched all my YouTube and they're like
we like your edge and all that [ __ ] so
just do you so I just play it safe I did
the sign I open for Seinfeld and I did
the Seinfeld set which you know nothing
cleaner than Seinfeld yeah so I go up
and out of the gate bom-bom-bom every
joke and I'm like girl let me pull out
some heavy-hitter these always work bomb
foolproof bomb so I'm like maybe I'll
get a little dirtier that's how I get
them I go I do a vibrator joke I study I
see a table of women get up and leave in
like a huff and I go that's not good
so I comment on them dry women huh yo
yeah yeah these women were not into it
and so I am I get off to like I bring
these people up to like give a little
speech about some kind of [ __ ] drugs
they're selling and I get off and the
CEO of the whole thing is yelling at me
and he's like how could you say that
about my wife and I'm like I don't even
know your wife is and he's like my wife
is offended get the hell out of here
you're fired you're done that was like
wait what what are you talkin a tuxedo I
rent the tux from Joseph a banks so I'm
like what so I go up to like the curator
lady and she's like she's crying as he
yelled at her first and he's like she's
like you gotta go you gotta go we're
gonna find someone else to host it the
whole that's three more hours in the
show and I just had to get in a car and
go back to Philly no I mean go back to
New York brutal I studied and all this
[ __ ] it was like a fine
lobster steak dinner and it was like so
high-end and this was a big production
with like a you know a sound booth guy
and the lighting guy and the waiters all
this [ __ ] and I just had to leave over a
joke she thought it was offensive to
women but the joke is so blah it's like
so innocuous but what's the joke the
joke is uh my girl use a vibrator and
you I say I feel like I uh I feel like
I'm obsolete now cuz the vibrant is
better than me I feel like this she's at
CVS I'm an employee there and she's
using the self-checkout you know and I'm
like hey if you need a hand I'm your man
you know like I feel like I'm losing my
job now I'm like these robots are taking
our job blah blah blah and I'm the loser
in the joke yeah you know I
she's the vibrator is better but she
took that as some of he's probably
gotten laid since 88 yeah taken out
me she's repressed she's gay I don't
know what's going on so I got I got the
the old boot yeah brutal but I got paid
oh you did you pay I got paid a good
agent
good agent yeah and it wasn't my fault
like I did the the material that did on
Conan you know so it's TV [ __ ] yeah that
doesn't sound good lady had some kind of
issue maybe she was having used a
vibrator a lot and things weren't going
well or something I think something was
up yeah she want to get railed by a
puberty Wilson or something was going on
and everybody in that crowd is probably
on opioids
yeah they're [ __ ] drug dealers
lectured me about morality and [ __ ] like
you guys sell pills oxy cotton to people
they get hooked and in Boston and then
they do heroin kill themselves like I'm
the bad guy telling zingers yeah you're
[ __ ] you're trying to get sohma's
into Lunchables yeah great that's what
I'm saying what the priorities we're all
out of whack you know something for some
reason jokes really hit people like hit
a nerve with people I don't know what it
is but like I noticed that we booked I
noticed sometimes things will get me
edges like I'm like oh um like I'm
reacting to things like I am becoming
part of the problem that I even Skol I
think we're all human right I noticed
this sometimes I'm like though like damn
this thing really has me like bent this
is somebody's tweeters I really do it
like what's going on here right right
like the white male straight white male
blah blah and you're like that's about
me yeah just like yeah I don't know
sometimes I found myself getting like
trigger by [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah what
happens it happens but you go alright
I'm triggered and you're not gonna go
get somebody fired right you would never
do that now you would go [ __ ] why did
that bother and you gotta sit with it a
little bit maybe but just to have that
gut reaction to just like ruin this guy
[ __ ] you you made me feel weird for one
second you're done yeah that's a crazy
instinct well we've given thing that's
going on is there's something that's
making us why do we feel weird like why
like the feeling of us feeling weird
about something has been magnified so
yeah it used to be like somebody told a
joke it made me if maybe maybe we feel a
certain type of way or something a
little bit that was very small I was
more focused on how is this gonna make
me laugh yeah just even sometimes I
would pretend a lie
yeah of course just to eat just to enjoy
myself yes yes now there's this whatever
the muscle or the react the reactor
inside of us that wants to wants to be
upset yeah that thing is stronger now
yeah yeah that's true you're right
that's a good point it's just it's
become stronger I think because the more
comfort you have the less tough skin you
have maybe like we were so used to
comfort that when you feel a little bit
of discomfort you're like oh this is
weird I gotta put it I gotta shut this
down and I think people like cancelling
and like being morally superior on
Twitter and just shouting out a guy I
think makes you feel good also it gives
you a little power like I got that guy
kicked off SNL how cool am i I'm great
teas races I'm great
yeah I saw an interesting thing I don't
want to say any names but I was at the
comedy [ __ ] Rivers I said a comedy club
in New York and we're all talking
hanging out this lady was there she's an
LA comic and Shane Gilles walked up and
he goes hey yeah she goes hey I'm will
say Leslie and he goes yeah I know you
are you [ __ ] on me on Twitter after the
whole thing breaker
no no and he goes she goes I did who are
you she don't you know who he was and he
goes I'm Shane Gillis and she said oh
really wow you know I never ah I was
just you know going with the flow
everybody was [ __ ] on you I just
jumped on the bandwagon like I never put
it together now that we're face-to-face
it's weird and he was like yeah again
it's cool and that was it but it was
cool seeing it in real life right not
just you know screens right so that was
fun because we the screens can make you
do anything you got no remorse yeah you
suck kill yourself
you know and then they do it you got
[ __ ] that's real it's the same thing in
you know what that goes it's the same
thing with pornography it's like yes
yeah of course way yeah if that were a
real person you wouldn't be behaving
that way because you have a wife or you
have a garage right because it's on this
screen it makes it its distant right its
distant but it still has this residual
effect and then the effect that you see
in the world from that like it's so
funny when that when people were ripping
on re the other day when it first
happened you know getting an re Shaffir
and cancel em and then the funniest part
to me was people calling him a white
supremacist that's the go-to now all
right I think sometimes he's kind of a
Jewish supremacist I think
I'm sure all new Act you know yeah it's
always would be a good name for it yeah
that's what Judaism in in itself is
supreme' they call themselves the chosen
one yeah well you think you're better
than me you [ __ ] Jew yeah I thought
the chosen one was Carmelo Anthony yeah
ain't no he also thought the first time
were Carmelo Anthony is it well I
thought it was a candy dude and I was
like a blue caramel oh oh did he not
have a bar I know that sounds great I'd
have two of them yeah it made me uh but
I started he guy was like oh yeah people
are pissed at Ari man he fought and I
just noticed my brain starting to go
down this little yeah what happens it
happens he really [ __ ] up you know
what's going like it's the mob and tell
with the torches and you go oh we're
burning this lady let's burn her
yeah don't burn me from there you had to
be there and do that's true that's true
now you got you know Larry ruckus
sitting on his couch
he worked ever and he's like you know he
has twenty forty thousand tweets right
if you have over eleven thousand tweets
dude I should give you an amount per
year yes there you go you really want to
use one on this this little situation
I'm her one time in high school I was
hanging out my friend he's like my he
didn't go to my high school we went to
his football game yeah and I'm sit in
the stands and you start rooting that's
not my school I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't care what happens to these kids
will you start rooting and it's the same
thing it's you want to be a part of
something yeah you know you get on
Twitter you know my whole thing with
like the re stuff and all this can't
like I just don't care like who gives a
[ __ ] yeah I already said something crazy
all right so what go go buy your
groceries go jerk off go hug your kids
right who has that much who has too much
time to care yeah I like thinking about
it like it's interesting to think about
why it happened what sure what's going
on like if there was something in his
head if he thought before like but
you're already a step ahead if you're
sitting back and thinking not
everybody's just going off just gut like
primal monkey [ __ ] you're thinking about
it it's this weird thing that we want to
be yeah you're right I want to find a
way how do I be better than this person
yeah why does this bother people why did
he do it what's he trying to get out of
it like that's already you're you're
better off your mind is a little more
open it's interesting try to keep it
open again it can get closed pretty
quick but yeah
well it's easy to go gut it's so easy
yeah and we always go the easy road you
know I had a tweet that had to pull down
and thankfully I did I mean some lady I
said Lakers and nicker and Knicks you
know on the television the other day and
they thought she said the n-word do you
see that yeah so right after I was like
people started sharing that so I took
the some guys like can you believe this
lady said this she needs to be ruined
right or whatever and I was like I had a
tweet it was like so what you know no
matter how many times she says that are
something is not gonna bring him back
you know and kind of like edgy funny you
know heavy stuff from the feed but
immediately let me make sure that's
exactly what I said so what it's not it
still won't bring him back yeah like
that was this ridiculous idea sure that
if you said the n-word enough who would
bring somebody back from the dead right
right
you hear the lady say it yeah let's do
it
million five views it did sound like it
really good oh I think that they
adjusted the audio in that one it is a
little bit of pause yeah there's a bit
of a hitch of the video right see what's
crazy is so 1.5 million people if they
did adjust that audio you have no idea
and then they and now 1.5 million people
think that the lady said that and is she
fired or what happened I don't think so
she did an apology Chris D'Elia had a
good tweet I think yesterday or this
morning earlier today while reporting
D'Elia has good takes on like just
reality yeah because we get all worked
up and [ __ ] and then he's like he just
kind of cuts to the this is dumb and you
know it and this is why yeah he's like
anybody yeah imagine thinking she
actually was so secretly racist and you
just want to virtues signal you feeling
guilty about your own racism want people
to think you're not a racist right I
think there's some truth to that agreed
100% like you know you make a joke about
watermelon so my goes hey that's racist
you're like I don't even mention black
people you went there yeah what's your
brain doing
yeah some of that stuff's ridiculous and
that's where I think sometimes Hollywood
gets all cornered up because they've
shut themselves as painted themselves
into this incapable space to be human
yes well said so true and that's why I
come out of the gate going I'm a piece
of [ __ ] I suck I'm a degenerate I like
blow and [ __ ] you know because I I
don't want to fall into that world it's
funny though cuz it's true yeah like it
feels like those guys in Hollywood are
all on a reality show and you said [ __ ]
so now you're you're out the house you
got eliminated you're done like louis
c.k got eliminated you know you're like
ah just eliminate me now like I don't
want to play I don't want to be in the
house yeah I just want to do blow yes
[ __ ] in the yard on there right right and
I'm not a bad guy and I have no
homophobic daughter I don't even give a
[ __ ] but but I've noticed that the
ballbusting because New York has gotten
kind of so woky and everything that the
ballbusting is gone LA it used to be
like tough crowd patrisse Colin Quinn
DePalo Norton Keith Robinson that those
days are over you know the Paulo's gone
wacky political Colin Quinn's gone
one-man show whatever but like the ball
busting now is you guys you and D'Elia
and Swardson and Shaab and Callen and
those guys are all making fun of each
other and it's it's nice to see it again
it's all gone LA somehow yeah I do
notice sometimes like yeah it is uh like
it specially on King in this thing is
it's a fun place where we can like just
rip each other
yeah I know and we have all selfie we
have other people like we have a little
bit of diversity on there so it's like a
fun place where we can talk about you
know joke about race and write like I'm
growing up do it I remember if you said
the n-word
that's how if somebody beat your ass
that's how you knew if you could say it
or not right right yeah that's how you
knew yeah but it was a lot of intent to
like not intent but you could feel oh
the heat behind it you know like I said
this on Rogen but in my neighborhood you
could feel it if it's the same words
like [ __ ] you white boy and then yeah
[ __ ] you white boy it's the same words
but it was a way different feeling like
if I was on a basketball court and I
heard the first one I was like I'm out
of here
right here the second one and I'm get a
guy in a headlock and noogie him right
off vitriol noogie please yeah trio whoo
Johnson one of them has yeah it's good
if I was like Michaels some of the
craziest names oh yeah growing up oh
yeah but now I'm like dude some like you
gotta have a unique name and a lot of
his freakin dope you know yeah of course
you stand out but now hongki's have gone
like Gwyneth Paltrow's got a kid named
Apple yeah so we have our own white
version of weird they got like de quante
or whatever the [ __ ] and we got like
lighthouse I think it's Jason Lee's kid
his named lighthouse that's insane give
that a give that a goog there will you
NIC lighthouse if they did lighthouse
for the blind I would love it
also how risky to put a light you'd
leading the blind right next to the
program water bro Yeah right damn that
was GPS back in it every time I see that
Adam like this is insane man how does
this end you know right blind people you
ever think about like they just got a
deal with that we had a girl in here a
blonde person what yeah really
yes one of my most popular episodes I
mean just talking about what it was like
she said she can relate sometimes to
computers because that's how her brain
feels it's like the more it goes along
certain paths and stuff yeah more it
gets used and gets comfortable in that
path and like knowing what's going on
interesting how key like sound is to
them yeah of course and how they can
feel how other people are feeling a lot
whoa are we talking about the actor
Jason Lee I thought so he's got one name
Casper one they call birdie oh maybe I
had the wrong guy passwords pretty
intense somebody's got a wacky name like
light house or light fixture light beer
I can't remember
I might have lighthouse wrong it could
be a ferry maybe you ever take that
ferry over there from New Orleans over
to the West Bank
yeah sure Mardi Gras world that would go
there yeah I used to take that with my
dad all the time I love that Ferry was
like a buck yeah that was good times
yeah that thing was good never accosted
a dollar to get into New Orleans from
the West Bank
every day those my friends are to pay a
buck to get into the city they got rid
of that but that was weird as a kid like
damn that's kind of shitty to the
wankers yeah it really is kind of yeah
got a pain to get in here yeah you have
to come over there to work and you also
got a pen yeah because it was like that
come from and Aviles I get it pay yeah
uh oh really it was a dollar and then
was a dollar fifty on each side Danny
then eventually it was just three
dollars in one way Dan so the other way
you did enough to stop eating paid three
dollars up top longest bridge in America
yep I think it was the longest bridge in
the world for a while and then Japanese
built one longer I got caught on that
bridge about to get murdered mm-hmm I
don't have you heard about this but we
were stopped on the causeway because I
we were getting chased by this guy who
was trying to kill us
me and a couple high school friends and
there was an accident on the causeway so
it was gridlocked so the car had to park
and we're like [ __ ] and he got out he
was like shaking the car he was like a
big buff guy and we were like three
squirrely Catholic school kids and he
had a knife he was like slicing the side
of the car up and luckily the cops at
the wreck saw it and like tased him and
pulled him down and a cuffed him that's
amazing it was wild but I was like going
the cause but he won't follow us because
it's too long but then there was a
[ __ ] wreck that causeway man
that was a whole nother world over there
where you live I was like I don't know
what goes on in Covington and Mandeville
and all that [ __ ] that was a I didn't
know what that was God just why I got
what yeah I was just kind of suburban
and then it just got a little bit weird
the further you got out yeah well I went
to LSU for a while a bunch of guys I
live with we're from Mandeville and
these were tough rambling dudes like
they could fish and skinned of Fox and
like you know fight and you know smoking
weed would really be worthy one guy was
in Gabe McCormack one guy was him Jared
Smedley these were like like backyard
right rough-and-tumble kind of guys yeah
like cage any dudes yeah and I was glad
I was friends with him because they were
like tough dudes they saw him fistfight
all the time
oh wow yeah like that would headbutt a
dude and they'd be wearing polo shirts
and a woven belt and just knock a guy
out of the football game like Dan they
were like my size they weren't big guys
or anything just braids they had a
little bit of bravery huh yeah they
would had they had like their own knives
that knives in the room and you know
make knives
yeah yeah it was like prison II yeah you
know yeah no weird scar on their head
and [ __ ] good guys yeah yeah they knew
how to make up
out of a log and [ __ ] yeah be wrong yeah
that P wrong man oh yeah they could
catch a crab with their hand out of
water and like they could pick up a rock
and go all right the winds going that
way like they knew it they were almost
like a little Cherokee in their ass yeah
it was interesting I think a lot of
people have a little bit and they put a
little chunk of mud under their tongue
you know Pisces or not exactly exactly
yeah and I came from the city so I was
like I don't know what the [ __ ] this is
you know but uh yeah cool cool guys LSU
did you enjoy your time over there what
was it like I did but I lived in a house
with four guys and we had a hot tub and
a beer pong table so I failed I fell out
of three colleges and I eventually got
into southeastern and I finished online
hell yeah dude hey you're a lion I guess
I guess so yeah yeah dude from hamon
yeah it was a good school I liked it
it's a good school man it's a nice
little place of it I went over there to
a pumpkin carving contest one time oh
nice we drove over there practice for
months dude yeah I got everything I just
got to nervous and ate [ __ ] ah I just
did Lafayette and they were like do was
just here it was like the talk of the
town oh yeah I did a that was a holiday
no Doubletree Hotel Jason Leonard's got
this show and it's killer it's like 300
plus seats great show and they were like
Theo was just here and I was like I
don't do it was fun oh that's cool yeah
people ask about you all the time man
come on they do they're always like oh
yeah you and Marc normal are for the
same place right you guys you probably
one of the most requested people who
have had to have on the podcast I'll
take it
I think people expect me because I'm
from New Orleans to be like I come in on
a gator and I got a [ __ ]
three-cornered hat on and [ __ ] you know
but yeah it was just a city yeah we ate
weird food I guess and listened to
zydeco and Mardi Gras and Mardi Gras
that was the best two weeks of school
what you did I mean st. Charles Avenue
oh yes so much fun never seventh Street
that's where all the kids hung out do
drugs and get drunk and make out and
finger girls and each other out by the
bushes and all that [ __ ] and I remember
making out with a girl who had cigarette
breath and it was like so hot to me
because she was so like adults
yeah good times guy that's fun and you
could drink outside there I got it I got
knocked out on st. Charles one time dude
I got knocked out on st. Charles but
least circle oh [ __ ] what was it a tall
blond hair dude like two like I mean 230
pounds yeah now I wish it was like a
college guy just like a fat doughy you
know chunky white guy you could have
beat that guy try to beat him or not he
snuck me as knees to say that's that's
one thing I don't like that happens in
Louisiana yeah yeah sneak [ __ ]
that's the kind of [ __ ] that I did not
like that happened a lot all the time
yeah I was it was a weird story I mean a
couple friends were hanging out drinking
and these kids like older kids a little
boy caught a spear and the spear was
like a big one that was like a big
ticket item and more nice yeah they were
nice and you caught one of those like oh
[ __ ] well done yeah and these older kids
were like give me the [ __ ] spear
Kenny was like no it's mine and we're
like hey you leave the kid alone it's a
spear what are you crazy like you're 18
19 20 what are you crazy and then who
the [ __ ] are you so they start pushing
us so we start pushing them and then one
of my friends got pushed and this is
like out of a movie the other guy
squatted behind him like an ottoman he
fell over oh so they start stomping on
my Donati's yes I got hit and I go down
and I remember see I'm laying on the
sidewalk looking at my friend getting
smushed by like a Doc Martin yeah you
know and I was like this is bad
so we lost pretty quick we had the one
black friend who was swinging away but
uh the cops came and broke it up and
we're like alright well that was crazy
we're all banged up and shipped we're
like uh what are you gonna do give me
another beer and then we go walk like a
block and I'm talking to my girlfriend
at the time and she goes I think I think
that's one of those guys and I was like
huh and I looked the wrong way and he
was running this way running start hit
me I went out and pissed myself Oh
which is the most embarrassing thing I
mean not only getting knocked out but
urinating and you see done that so much
as a child I guess I guess I got a weak
dick stop piss stop or something I got
no cork yeah and I went out and I was
laying on like drooling and pissing on
myself which is pretty embarrassing and
I woke up like two minutes later and my
girlfriend like get out of here like
swinging her purse
worse oh I'd rather look like you owe me
the night girlfriend standing there
saying get out of here brutal man yeah
oh I was brutal man that's worse do cuz
that ruins your Marty girl you know
completely and I had a [ __ ] egg whap
right here it was rough and yeah that
was bad like have lunch with my mom the
next day she's like what happened I was
like I fell down the stairs I got hit by
a doorknob brutal brutal it humbles you
yeah it definitely makes you think about
yeah like yeah you get it you get
knocked around a couple times you get a
little bit wiser yes say at a certain
situation definitely don't ask questions
don't run your mouth you can notice when
things are just starting to yeah yeah oh
yeah you can fit a spidey sense is
tingling and I saw been those [ __ ]
Baton Rouge guys were daint they would
kick you in the face yeah like at a bar
and [ __ ] like in the parking lot there
the fights out there well why I've got
more risque yeah there ton of fights at
LSU man oh yeah I remember being in a
parking lot one time and somebody threw
a beer bottle and went right by my head
I was like it's nobody I didn't know
anybody was like somebody's it's cray
you know I'm just not I have aspirations
um dude yeah I remember one time we're
walking down the street in this big
white dude I think he was on steroids
and he walked past us and was me and a
couple of my buddies and he goes oh he
turned rise like when y'all called me
the n-word and we're lying no way dude
I'm not blind
yeah bloody crazy yeah bro he [ __ ]
decks one of my buddies right oh [ __ ]
yeah they had like a piece of just a
piece of like I was like a not a 2x4 but
like it may be a 1x2 or something like a
really thick dowel rod right there just
leaning on this phantoms Mardi Gras
somebody made a sign and left it I just
picked it up and just snap this guy with
it really yeah he hit me he had my buddy
that didn't knock him down here who is
this n-word this white Edward is a beast
bro it did not know this guy was huge
man something like he was just
unbeatable you know yeah it was like the
first time you get to like this super
like them like the balls are yeah like
oh I don't know where he jumps right
yeah I gotta play it a few times to get
his rhythm yeah yeah you know this cows
and some girls pull up the only girls we
even knew they we had any chance with
their Mardi Gras pull up and the like
and for some reason I kind of like
falling off to the side of the fight and
like hey what do you guys do and it was
like like all this guy was it look like
we're doing no joke the girl goes okay
well we're just gonna find a place to
park for parking I like that gal she's
not fazed by [ __ ] so maybe like crack me
right in the middle of the head and just
horrible big red well yeah yeah and I
got some ass out of a thing and tried to
fake that a Schwinn Oh
smart smart move you should have gone
full Muslim just to put that dot down
there Wow
he got you right here oh man he got me
right there man and yeah it definitely
kind of woke me up like it shook my head
a little sure it almost made me feel
pretty cool yeah you get a rush and you
feel alive yeah yeah like oh right oh
man I can get knocked out yeah it's very
primal you know like we grew up and I
grew up when we evolved fighting yeah
and so it's something in yeah yeah you
picked that stick up pretty quick yeah
you weren't like should I pick up the
stick you just went for it
yeah it was fun hitting him too right in
the neck I bet I can't believe that
didn't knock him out Oh knocking down at
least no not this guy yeah I heard him
about 40 times for me to go down Wow
it was right here was the worst part
right when I picked it up I realized it
wasn't that strong it was like I wished
it was like limbs II wasn't that sturdy
yeah that's it was almost like slapping
somebody with a piece of wood you got a
guy like a paint stirrer that sucks he
just made a man right they started
blinking like on the screen good right
right you needed a flower to fireball
damn what else did we cover everything
Nick you got anything any questions uh
all the good ones you the other ones you
kind of answered in within conversation
oh all right all right
hope we weren't too serious hope there
was some meet some yuxin all right yeah
I thought it was fun man it just also
just nice to get to chat we never really
got to sit on a chat that much it's the
beauty of pods man it brings people
together like I have friends who I don't
see unless we podcast
it's kind of sad but we're working we're
always busy yeah what's it like at the
cellar these days over there it's
different it's definitely more you know
diverse and like spread out and no one
calls anybody on [ __ ] which I think like
I'm all for diversity and I'm all for
our new people and hanging out and
different voices but it was a it was a
better place when you were more honest
now it's like well this is a gay trance
or whatever so I'm not gonna push it
right you know but he might have a hacky
joke that I heard before but I'm like I
don't want to just ruffle any feathers
cuz I don't wanna seem like I'm this guy
right so I think is worse that's not
progress right I thought about treat
everybody equally but we're so nervous
about stepping on toes and being called
phobic this and that so like that part's
weird man yeah that seems like a really
tough environment yeah like back and a
Patrice would go what the [ __ ] is that
hat you know and you can't do that now
he's like I don't know if that hats a
[ __ ] garb or yeah that's like a
service hat right right right now I'm
classist or some [ __ ] so yeah it's it's
different you got to watch your P's and
Q's where before it was like you just
kind of shot from the hip which I think
there's some goodness to that you know
yeah you don't a football coach who's
going hey yeah everything was great now
you got a guy go hey you [ __ ] that up
do that again get down on four knees and
this and that take a knee whatever but
yeah so we're missing that part but it's
still a great club yeah oh yeah man that
place is legendary have you worked there
ever yeah
Schumer and Neal Brennan helped me get
past there nice all right it's I mean
it's a tight comedy box laughs Oh nurse
even when I went back there last time
look like maybe four months ago up a
street I don't even go perform I just
went by to say and I was just like so
nervous just see ya and there it's weird
I mean the store used to be like that
but the stores kind of gotten more
welcoming yeah yeah definitely yeah I
think well there's so many comics so
there's so many people there usually at
night ya know a lot more people now
right right that helps yeah I mean you
definitely people you know you see
Martin only people like oh yeah right
I'm not gonna lie to you like a couple
years ago I'd see you and just like uh I
don't know anybody was like high school
at the cafeteria like we have some
connection I need you but you were doing
[ __ ] you were busy and I was like all
right no I gotta I gotta learn to just
sit here alone damn but you know you
know how it is when you're your
different you want to [ __ ] cling to
some guy oh yeah totally yeah it's funny
it's like the things that we it's like
so easily like if you know like say like
a missile hit oh be interesting to see
how quick people got into like no what
would it make attract people to
different people and get into certain
groups and cliques for sure for sure I
always say like remember World War 3 was
about to happen you know but Trump
everything with Iran yeah yeah and
everybody's like this is awful and you
know everybody's got jokes about it I'm
like it's not that bad if you're
checking your retweets you know if
you're checking your retweets it's not
really an emergency we all pretend like
we're living in this crisis time and
everything's gonna fire around us you
know but if you're going here's my Trump
joke how's that doing things aren't that
bad
if your house is on fire you're not
tweeting [ __ ] you know what I mean
so that's how you kind of know if things
are really bad and then of course it
would turned into nothing and nobody
cared
ten minutes later but yeah I feel like
that's a good point cuz people are gonna
my dad used to always say we need a war
we need a war people are black for his
way rich versus poor men versus women we
need a war to bring us all together
which is not a great mentality but I
thought about that before yeah like you
need some kind of common enemy like we
used to hate the Nazis then we hated the
Russians and you know you got to have
some kind of bonding factor which we
don't really have anymore buddies doing
their own [ __ ] you got a pod he's got a
web series
she's a diorama yeah he's got an easel
he's like I got a compass
that's a Demetri Martin reference yes
guys know what's going on here we should
do a show I would love that it'd be
great we could sell out the mahalia or
uh that's pretty big that Sanger might
be cool Oh me you Patton I can be fun
fun I can be fun my uh my dad's kid from
his first marriage bought that place
yeah he owned that Keystone that bar
right there on your shirt my dad's son
from his first marriage yeah oh so a
half-brother yeah there's like he died
he's accidentally died in the woods he
accidentally got shot but he was like 68
or 70 I think yeah once ago they must
been a big hitter I mean he did it yeah
they did well it was crazy because we
didn't have anything yeah this old dad
and he had this other family from you
know 30 years earlier that's wild and
they owned
Tipitina's and they owned like all this
nice stuff so could you come into town
and get kind of wined and dined no damn
but I had like a common enemy though
haha [ __ ] them
there you go you know yeah my half bro
yeah I hooked me up with some tickets
yeah get me in there do you don't want
to see uh Disco Biscuits tonight how
does he bag of doughnuts yeah remember
them oh do remember them they played
nine of my prom are the only band them
yeah album out yes and we had better
than Ezra I think better that's what I
really liked I did to do the wet grass
falling a step behind that's all I knew
yeah me too
uh dude bagging dude first of all cowboy
mouth they can't play everything dude no
be it nine things if you're alright they
be at a um I see you open yeah they
would be listening yeah everyone Mitzvah
yeah going on then they had the
radiators was a big radiators they open
up a restaurant in the North Shore
Mandeville called Mandy's restaurant oh
[ __ ] I didn't know real biscuits brought
so good all right Franklin the radiators
owns it and then they had a what was the
oh the brass band rebirth rebirth
rebirth was big
rebirth yeah about ten years ago or
twelve years ago they really like out on
a national level yeah that's right they
played on all the football games and
stuff Wow
good for them I used them in my first
special I played rebirth to open it up
oh really yeah dude I've played Ricky B
oh oh shake it for you here of course I
grew up on that song yeah bounce wrap
yeah was it partners in crime people
yeah [ __ ] go yes and they all had
danced certain dances with it [ __ ] I
knew all that stuff dude they played I
don't let him hoes bro no joke at my
uncle's funeral how crazy is that
like that's Louisiana day yeah yeah we
used to go to a [ __ ] uh what was that
a me so horny was that band 2 Live Crew
oh oh that's a great show yeah one of
them was on Tom Segura podcast recently
oh [ __ ] your mom says live I think
Lonnie live or whatever that man's name
was oh wow
might have been crew I don't know who it
was one of them dude yeah good time what
back it done they were pretty good I
wonder if they like moved on and did it
with a in and they were always shooting
toilet paper at the right there that's
all a paper gun yeah that's it that
support people didn't take them as
serious right they became like hype men
yes yeah yeah they were a great like I
remember they come over to the North
Shore and play and people would go nuts
go nuts just come yeah I saw a frat
party and I was like how'd you get them
oh yeah you guys have some money yeah or
who's I got I don't want to work and I
got ha afroman
he was big I don't think he was from
there but he blew up there
wanna be my yeah bro I saw him one time
he was so drunk on a stage he vomited in
his hat and just threw it off the back
of the stage and just kept saying damn
at old Miss University Wow I saw him
live once and he had all these other
songs everyone's kind of like alright
then he played I got high everyone's
like and anyway back the other one we're
like alright let's get out of here I
felt bad for that's all they wanted to
hear I mean let's be honest
do ya man and one thing I loved about
being around Louisiana especially one
was just going to get oyster that was
something that's nice all the time
Louisville of an oyster on the half
shell not people won't like it yeah it's
crazy I mean I get it is a gooey snotty
thing out of a shell it's got a weird
consistency it's like a loogie is gay
but a girl will give a [ __ ] being and
have an oyster dude I'm out of here the
point yeah so no I'll break it always
try to the fridge just to see what her
vibe is right yeah yeah I love him but
uh you got I think you got to grow up
with him yeah same with Croft if you're
like why do you waste time it's so I'm
like it's about to hang we're at a table
we got a keg of beer we're throwing
shells in the hole in the table it's
great yeah everybody's sign it
everybody's got sinuses yeah uncle came
over and he's in a boot right right
that's a crazy slow walking right
[ __ ] buzz aldrin shows up yeah your
Nana's there you gotta peel him for her
she's friends with Rosa Parks you know
you can't even see yeah Rosa Parks is my
nickname for Cam Newton oh I like it
there pretty good that's pretty good
with the headdress
okay he's high he's a hot hot black man
what do you think happens to Drew Brees
man you have any insight I think he had
a good run I think his hair is going and
I think he's a cool dude and he's great
for the city but I mean I think time has
come yeah what do you all think it man I
mean he completed 73 percent of his
passes last year that's the crazy part
that's great right yeah yeah yes no I
like drew I'm a big guy he's like the
mayor you know if he came down to
Orleans and I in a convertible and just
waved I mean the [ __ ] shut buildings
would shut down and people jump out of
windows oh he's the guy yeah he's fun to
watch on this game he has his kids and
stuff oh I gotta what I gotta follow
three or four kids on there he's got
three little boys and a little girl does
he does he know you I'll tell you this
the only time I ever met him was at
lucey's huh Scott Fujita who was a
football player for the Saints brought
him out to the comedy show one night at
lucey's Wow my fiance's doing this Scott
afterwards act he stayed for the whole
show three I guess the worst lonk 22
comedian got him a corn bread yeah red
bean dust Muppet rude boy yeah
arteriosclerosis do this black set of
twins she actually he was Greek I think
Cheerios that sounds more Greek um yeah
that was a [ __ ] show
man they brought and then afterwards
Scott said oh hey this is our this is
the new quarterback this is your this is
Drew Wow so you saw a young drew and he
was nice yeah he just show can see I
don't have had and nobody knew who he'd
know buddy was maybe people knew but
nobody like nunu nunu yeah yeah
by the way it's gotta suck to be Scott
Vegeta because everybody's going fajita
now for Jada yeah
fajita Vegeta unless you open up a
restaurant editor
yeah it's sizzling Fujita's yeah yeah
that's not bad come get these Fujita's
in your mouth I love is there anything
better than if I heat a plate that
sizzle coming out you know yeah the
piping hot it's it's bubbling and
crackling and got the smoke everybody at
the tables jealous like damn man I got
looking at wonton yeah I got enchiladas
here you're sizzling yeah I used to
think it was a Mexican birthday cake
when they brought it I didn't know what
was going on right now it shows up and
you blow on it yeah you make a wish uh
mark Normand thanks for coming in man
when are you coming up where you gonna
be coming up in school Wednesdays come
out tomorrow oh great I'm at the La
Jolla Comedy Store tonight okay great
and all weekend and I'm doing the the
road and I'm finally selling tickets for
the love of Allah Jesus but I'm all my
dates are on mark Normand comedy calm
are they and um I got in my own podcast
called Tuesdays with stories see me in
New York follow me on Instagram queef
anal semen go nuts we'd love to have you
I'm all over the road this year so just
don't drive behind it yeah yeah yeah
I've been drinking so be careful up
there but I'm on a moped so yeah I
killed me more I kill you
you name it I'm coming Chicago Utah
Royal Oak all the good ones okay cool
thank you guys yeah thank you guys for
being here man thanks mark
yeah it's bumming
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself
[Music]